I'll still be here.
Hello, everyone.
Hello.
Just waiting on Wig Riton.
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Wig's here.
Hello.
You're live, right?
Yeah, I'm live, dude.
Okay, okay, because we're all live, too.
Just one of you streamed, you're live as well.
Immediately when I joined Call of Duty, dude, it's just
immediate serotonin throughout my whole brain.
Friends, it's so long.
this is gonna be so bad now yeah no it's so bad straight
downhill from there uh moxie was i was like moxie because he
uh he hasn't played apex in a year plus now so i was like
moxie you know like characters have upgrades now and he's
like yeah what oh fuck me dude i was like you know what
you're gonna upgrade right moxie and he's like um yeah yeah
let me let me chicken fire rings real quick like let me oh
we're so fucking cooked bro what oh my god that's who i'm
iGLing today yeah yeah you're iGLing you're guiding us
you're telling us what to do you're gonna first heard it
you're the jump leader you're everything great i believe in
you how many games is it six games it's like it's also like
i don't know how battlefly works because apparently there's
a lobby code and that comes from battlefly so i So you're
gonna, you're gonna, yeah.
Is it, wait, is it actually Battlefly or Battlefly?
Is it Battlefly?
I thought it was fly, I said, fly.
Oh, it's Battlefly.
Oh, okay.
I've always thought it was called Battlefly.
I was like, I was saying it wrong for like 18 years.
Yeah, I was like, that is so fucking stupid.
Wait, of course it's Battlefly.
In this motherfucker, we're so drunk.
I can't believe it.
the truth because they felt bad for you after 18 years after
fucking 46 years of knowing this game i was like the battle
fly no way i was like crisis like why did no one ever
corrected me like moxie moxie's good at other games though
he apparently he's really good at rivals right he's good at
he's good at over like hero shooters but this is not a hero
shooter so oh he doesn't put out in that same category which
is crazy he has 10 000 kills though of apex so like i don't
know apex is how old now um 40 000 years old i can't believe
how old it is i hate it so much he's like yeah you're like a
veteran holy i hate that dude i'm almost 30 isn't that crazy
oh that's crazy you're gonna be a hag soon a hag yeah that's
what people call in v2 returns you hit 30 you're literally a
hag the hag is actually wicked word bro i hate that your
life in the punch.
Oh my god, dude.
I don't even want to fucking think about that.
30 is crazy unc status, though.
I had some guy like the other week.
I think it was, now it was probably two months ago.
And he hit me with the dude.
I watched you in high school.
And like, now I'm graduating college.
I was like, bro, that's awesome.
Oh, shit.
I'm sick.
And I fucking hate you.
Congratulations.
I'm going to fuck with him.
At least it's not like, hey, I used to watch you in
elementary school.
And now I'm in college.
I know there's some people who are like that.
Dude, it's so crazy to think about, man.
Did you watch the uh vtube rewards at all or not or not
vtube awards the stream awards?
I watched a little bit of it.
I know there's a lot.
I saw like A lot of like clip a clip dating from There was a
lot going on dude.
It was interesting.
I got invited to go to like and then I was like, you know
Maybe people won't know I'm there, but then I saw that like
the fucking seating list was public and I was like Yeah, no,
I'm not.
Yeah, I'm not going.
Oh, no, you would have been spotted in two seconds Yeah, it
really says the name on the back of the seat.
No, yeah, you can't go.
Yeah I was just like, okay, yeah, no, I'm sorry.
I'm canceling.
Because at first I was gonna go.
And then they're like, and then people were like, you know,
here's the seating list, like showing the seating list to,
like, to their stream.
And I'm like, why is this public?
Right, you already got spotted.
Yeah, I wanted to be like, go there incognito, but there was
no incognito about it.
Dude, we could have got shots together.
I'm disappointed now.
Oh, wait, were you there?
Yeah, I was there, dude.
We could have got shots.
Oh, shit, you're right.
And then and then like my face would be posted everywhere.
I'm right.
We're getting drunk.
Hey, wait a minute.
I'm down.
Oh, dude, I'm winning.
It's one of these tournaments.
Yo.
Yeah.
So Whig is very, are you still sick, right?
Are you like cold or like what?
Dude, I've had like a cold for like seven days.
It's fucking me up so bad.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you're cook.
It's okay.
You're just being a watch party here because you can't you
don't have to get any kills for this tournament.
that with you i gotta get some kills i don't know apparently
your kills don't matter you don't we get zero points if you
kill anybody oh why are they acting like i'm the messiah of
apex that's insane it's like it's because monsoon and other
pro players are in this turn if it's there like it's not the
rule wait don't worry the rule is not for you i'm gonna say
i mean can we get an exception and a pass on the side.
Can Perry meet him on soon?
That's actually fucking egregious.
Wait, nice wig.
You actually play the game, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why is I'm not confident?
Why is he not confident in that acting?
It depends on like GG, nice wig on the team.
Like GG them, right?
Like GG the enemies.
Yeah, yeah.
People don't say GG, you have nice wig, right?
To us?
I mean, I think I might be the first person shittalked in
this chat when we go in that game.
Wait, is the lobby code out yet?
I don't know how lobby code works.
I don't know either.
I haven't done Battlefly in 18 years.
Okay, wait.
Oh, I found it.
Sorry, guys.
Okay, I found.
I'll message it to you guys.
I hope we're not the last team in.
Oh, nice.
All right.
We probably will be, I think.
We'll just kind of find it.
No, no, it's fine.
We'll just be like...
We're going to hide and seek with these codes.
Yeah, we're just having a good time with our buddies.
our friends we're just bonding okay private match wait can i
show the code can i can i put it in it'll be an asterisk
we're not last guys we're not the last people in it's okay
one team is not even in one whole team so wait what's the
meta where's that code oh i sent it to you oh you're a
genius thank you i love you i was gonna take me eight it was
so long to find that what okay let me get in there let me
get into there we go we're good okay wait what's the meta
like what character should we be playing okay so there's no
character bands nothing like we're good apparently there
will be later like in game two or some you guys even have
those in this game yeah we do we do yeah It's all I didn't
know, man.
It's been a long time.
Oh, wow.
You better start upgrading your abilities, Big Papa, when
we're in game.
Yeah, no, okay, I got that.
I mean, so this is, you're nice.
You're the brains of the team since you, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Probably the only thing I'm smart about is Apex.
Yeah, so let me tell you what you got on your team right
now, okay?
I'm okay at killing my movement.
I know a little bit.
I know the tap strafe, the wall bar.
Oh, my God.
What?
Okay, now we're active.
Yeah, we're active.
Okay.
I only have kills on Bangalore, Pathfinder.
And that's it.
10k kills on each, but I have like less than 50 on
everything else.
Good.
Okay, that's good.
That's not bad, because Bangalore's low-key kind of meta
right now.
Kind of meta.
But all my kills are on my own stream snipers who would
punch me, so they had no guns.
Okay, so that's fine.
Okay, maybe one of them won't have guns on them, you know?
Maybe we'll get lucky.
I'm going to have to get some luck then today.
Zuni's in the sloppy.
Oh, we're fine.
No, it's okay.
They're not allowed to have kills.
It's okay.
They're like you.
No, they're not, though.
That's the problem.
If they get kills on us, it don't matter.
They get nothing out of it.
Yeah, I'm actually going to tell them not to do anything.
Zuni, disconnect.
All right.
So, Begalore, Begalore is like pretty good, I would say.
Begalore, Valc are probably must-haves in a lobby like this.
Okay.
Just because we want to rotate with a Valculte, she got like
a crazy buff, so she's stupid broken.
It just depends how you guys want to play.
Do you want to sweat it out?
Do you want to like go to the end game and like just chill
inside zone?
Do you want to run down people and just say, fuck it, who
cares?
It's up to you guys.
Well, on the last game, we have to run down people because
placement points don't matter on the last game.
It's all about Moxie's kills.
Okay, perfect.
to boxy then okay got it i mean we could experiment we have
six games of experimentation here yeah is that the only
rules though game six is the only one with rules like well
game one to five it's like it's me and moxie kills count but
there's also placement points okay got it so it's like lgs
minus me yeah minus you don't exist as a person not at all
yeah yeah you'll get them loads like yourself it's fine you
get one v3 get them low we'll be there yeah we'll be there
we'll wait for that's not going to be the situation where
you guys like walk in you're like oh my god they're all low
because of nice week that's not going to happen oh you're
100 thieves nice wing you have a clan tag and everything are
you not pro i thought you played for the 100 thieves team
yeah right right now yes you're in like six years dude what
yeah for watching the game you still you still repping that
six years later six years later dude haven't let it go yet
bro my contract i'm gonna wait wait w hold on no no listen
seriously like i i think i'll be doing what the what did you
do what you're technically a react streamer you think about
it you're reacting to apex yeah i mean i hate that though i
can't allow it a while i'm not just sitting there once every
40 minutes just saying one comment didn't that's actually
crazy i think we run bangalore i'm gonna i'm gonna
completely just forget you said that we're gonna run
bangalore we're gonna run valk and then i mean alter do you
want to play not valk no i do not want to play valk wait i
also wait i also have a little bit of time on valk it's not
the greatest though yeah i don't keep you on bang baby yeah
i don't think i don't i'm not confident with that okay i'm
just i don't know i don't know maybe you guys want uh uh a c
tier valk instead of a b tier bank you know i don't know i
think we keep the b the b i mean c's get degrees yeah they
do they do though i do that's why i dropped out of community
college you only had d's not only c's maybe some f's too and
you passed right and look at you yeah yeah no actually the
last year of college i paid my brother to do my whole online
classes that's smart okay that's good he's a genius your
brother was literally chat gpt before existed so you didn't
drop out you withdrew i withdrew yeah exactly yeah same yep
all right so took you then who are you playing i can do out
alter alter oh okay i mean that's not bad yeah i could just
it's like mercy i send you out to die and And then I res
you.
I'd be like, I have res.
Die on point.
So I alter.
Oh, do you even know what alter does, Moxie?
I, I, uh, she has a teleporter.
She has like a portal through walls.
Okay.
That's it.
That's all I know.
Yeah.
Yep.
Teleporter through walls.
And then like her ulti is kind of like her ultimate.
It's like a, a nexus.
So you put it down and then she can recall you to it.
If you're not.
I just stay there.
And then send you guys out to die.
And then I'd bring you back.
You need to get in there.
your kills matter mine don't we need we need you okay if
that's the case you should be altered then i mean i can't if
you want me to you want me to be altered that no no because
i could not play valve for the life of me like i would
actually send us to die every time although i'll probably i
can see it every time somebody's not envision that happening
i landed six people like two fucking teams instead that's
okay I believe in us all right so we're playing altar
Bangalore Valk right yes okay okay we're on storm point our
POI is the wall okay the wall that's not bad I'll find that
on the map somewhere yeah don't worry we're gonna lay there
automatically I think right we're just gonna drop over there
get the downstairs from the wall because no one's there no
one got that pli part oh really okay then yeah i'll land
there and go yeah but there are teams surrounding that area
so do well are people like saying where they're dropping no
no no so now now in okay so pli was a okay moxie pli's now
signed so i love this uh so they added a new update so
there's no like jump leader anymore there's no jump master
so we just automatically land in the poi wow okay i thought
it was like some some type of aura stuff like whoa whoa whoa
a dokey nice way moxie's landing the wall like do not drop
there like i thought it was like everyone is like yeah we're
just like don't land there that's where we're landing also
they fucked up the team numbers like now did they forgot how
to count did they forgot like a number like what happened
this is at 20 our people are leaving no they're all going to
unassigned because they're all so i guess they missed the
number or some shit so we're on supposed to be number six so
i'm just waiting team one is the i got removed from the
match that's fine yeah they don't talk about us did we get
banned already well that was fun i can't believe it they
wait what oh yeah did you guys see the rule rule page it was
like apparently okay i didn't read the rules page my manager
read it and it was like 15 is long and i was like oh whoa
yeah we need chat chibi to put that in the summer yeah yeah
can you summarize this into one piece look he's so clutch
for that account i thought i used ai never remember you know
yeah yeah never never never never you're the reason why ram
prices are so high now it's your fault wig yeah 100 percent
thousand dollars for two gigabytes of ramp first place is 12
points okay so second is 9 37 fourth is fifth fifth is four
okay so we only get a point for going 15 or higher i get
should we get kills like is this like nice way you recognize
these a lot of these like players you think we could just
run them down you gotta be dopey on the team i think overall
average of like skill level i think say that confident.
You're so confident of your own skill of no, I'm talking
about mainly about you guys.
Oh, but super, you're so confident of us too.
And I'm like comparing you two to the other two.
Like, you know what I mean?
I think we're good.
But the main thing is kills will be great.
But like, I gotta, you know, make sure I don't die, but also
not get the kills in certain situations.
And that's kind of hard to do.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Well, if anyone can do it, it's you, though.
Yeah, I believe in you.
You can suppress that.
I think there's two more people that could definitely sure
so we'll get at least third place then that's good yeah yeah
at least third place also like if you start if you feel like
you're about to kill someone just unplug your controller
like that yeah yeah I'm on a MK now oh you're what I
switched up wait wait I don't like that you don't like that
wait why would you do that to yourself why dude every game
is so much more fun dude wait what the fuck you guys don't
like my my skill level without aim assist i mean so i'm just
look the immediate switch up was diabolical uh you know okay
so there's a key word there aim assist and you know i'm
stealing every kill tonight now every so until i can i would
like some assist yeah i would like some assist with my aim
like why would that let's take that away from yourself yeah
it's just listen Cross like what am I gonna do play Marvel
rivals on controller like it's just not it.
It's not it people do it Yeah, some people do it the one of
the best controller players is a controller player Yeah, he
was on a hundred thieves.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, so like you can do it You just gotta
try harder Dude, I'm not good enough no more man the hands
don't work like that.
You know what I'm saying?
I feel like it like controller playing is like max wind
comfortable like you get to lean back You could stand up and
like exactly, you know, like it's It sounds like I'm
jealous.
You get to slouch and play the game and still do it all
because you got the aim assist.
You got the skills.
Oh, fuck this, man.
Listen, dude.
Come on, wig.
Come on.
Plug in that.
Apex people knowing aim assist OP.
Exactly.
You hear me read that comment out?
Yeah, you guys know it's OP.
It is, dude.
But like, listen, the MK is just too comfy.
I like it more.
You know, my back hurts less for some reason.
I'm reaching 30 now.
I got to keep my motor skills going.
It just locks in.
It's nice.
Okay.
I'm going to have to shit talk monsoon real quick.
One sec.
Okay.
You know, I relied a lot on wig being on aim assist just to
find out he's not on aim.
Doki, you said we had this in the back.
Like, nice to go on the roller.
How was I supposed to know he swapped inputs?
That's me.
You know, I'm here yesterday.
I'm writing this call.
I thought you were saying something.
Yeah, I thought we had something about soon.
Yeah, you said you were talking about.
Yeah.
I know it.
No, no, no, no, in the chat.
I don't actually, I want you guys to have your moment real
quick.
One sec.
Can I join, can I actually join teams?
Yeah, he can.
I don't know, he know where he is.
I was just a little bitch out, bro.
So how do you guys get in this head, dude?
One second.
I didn't think he would just swap inputs.
He's been on controller for like four years.
And now he's on FNC.
Like, I'm not familiar with the pro scene.
He's talking a lot about this monsoon guy.
Is he like a pro winner tournament?
the back like clapper well he's going to land in japan for
next year so yeah but it's okay his kills don't matter it's
okay it's okay he's also got carried there or something or
something i don't know well he's sort of the igl of his team
so um yeah yeah it's okay it's okay it's okay we could we
can get second place they can be first and then we'll we'll
be we'll be not last
believe i believe in us i've recruited monsoon to join up
he's gonna be a four man for us oh really oh that's great
nice okay so like he should he won't shoot us right if he
sees us i think he's gonna do you think he's gonna shoot us
a lot yeah with a charge rifle too probably but his kills
don't count okay but so that's good we don't give points
yeah we don't give yes exactly wait that's the strap let's
just run into him he has to kill us or we just kill him
obviously you got it you you just won one of them nice i
don't think he's winning the one i don't think he's gonna
win that one v1 moxie i dude guys come on i'm definitely not
why are we even discussing this obviously not it's not even
close moxie i hate to break it to you oh my god bro blurs in
the lobby too we might be fourth place oh it's okay his
kills don't matter we just remember true true oh my god
floating's in here as well all right we're fifth place i'm
think okay oh no i see cutie as well yeah we might be six i
think we're six wait wait six okay we're still top half yeah
yeah we're still top 10 no and blink and saying i think we
dropped down eight guys i gotta that's still top 10 top 10
guys i'm gonna stop reading these names i'm gonna stop
reading these names i think we're fight boxy i think no it
really just depends on you guys you know i don't think the
pressure is really on me today i think it's more on you guys
a soldier only needs a good leader that's me that's me yeah
is it but our ball all bark no bite yes exactly but a leader
should also instill confidence and i'm not feeling very
confident right now we got great peel or great peel wise
great team composition nice wig is this your main account no
not my main account no no okay okay wait why are you okay
are you yeah he's looking at your
He pulls out your name on the tracker, on the Apex tracker.
Oh my god.
I saw you have 28k kills.
I have 20.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, shit.
Wait, no, this is my main account.
Oh, yeah.
This is.
Oh, I have multiple.
I have multiple.
That's that's awkward, bro.
I'm pretty sure like 24,000 of those kills were all octane
too.
That's okay.
That's a little awkward.
We don't have to.
almost like almost almost there with his kills like you know
he's our tier three player hey dude wait whoa guys i'm even
forgetting the pro player arc that i had here like two years
those yeah but a lot of stuff probably but when was those
two years how long ago last two years like probably the last
two years yeah yeah right 25 20 24.
yeah right uh yeah no 2020 2021 oh okay okay yeah i mean you
guys need confidence but i'm not really hearing a lot of
hype up about me you know what i'm saying yeah but i just
got pocket wash on a banner dude that was insane i was just
seeing like okay how much am i like outskilled here you know
i was like okay wait this guy's probably the main game
probably like quadruple five times ten times my kills ten
times your kills bro when i don't go outside 100k kills is
wicked don't rush to 520 oh fuck yeah so yeah and i haven't
played really since like season three wait this wait one of
their pro players have 63 000 kills wig where's your 63k
kills i need a straight i'm gonna get my therapist after
this one dude i'm gonna need an emergency session
help.
That's just my love.
Psychiatry.
I'm torched.
It's okay.
Kareem Cheese has 18K.
No, Kareem Cheese has 18K kills.
Yeah, yeah, you're better than him.
But he reacts to anime.
It's not even his main job.
Oh.
There's a reason he commentates and doesn't play.
Lull.
What the fuck's that about?
Yeah, mods.
Just get rid of that guy.
No, you should.
him yeah be that guy actually yeah who modded him that's not
my okay someone said he's just been reacting to them getting
kills that was my that was my mod so i can't ban him wig i'm
sorry no it's fine it's fine it's cool just give me his name
yeah so you get him i'm not 30 yet why am i getting this
stream i'm not 30 yet i feel like that's what you do like
the 35 40 year old players you know in the lobbies and stuff
nice way if you're not confident dude we got imperial halal
in your chat i've seen oh wait wait are you does like how
live nearby can you like imperial halal yeah can you call
him up real quick she's probably not busy yeah he's probably
not busy he's in your chat right now yeah listen ben how am
i supposed to compete with the fucking six-time world
champion.
They give me a fucking break.
Does he live close by?
Can he call him up real quick?
I'm about to fuck him.
I'm in eight shots, all of us, but I'm going to switch to
the gambling stream.
Nice week beat Prime CSM.
I did.
Wait, VIP that guy.
Tell me go in my chat.
Hey, oh, March soon.
Where are we landing?
We're landing wall, bro.
Come through.
Wall?
Got you.
All right.
Oh, no, wait.
This is resort, resort, resort.
Resort, resort.
Mm-hmm.
Wait, I think they might run into I think they're gonna Run
and kill us and resort like I think you just give him Intel.
I think you just get I forgot we don't have a drop ship dude
Wow, fuck yeah, I don't think about that one.
He's definitely gonna kill us, but it doesn't matter if he
does Yeah, yeah, zero point.
Zero point.
Yeah.
Yeah, what just one of us has to live so we can get rid of
said residents Yeah, for sure.
Yeah All right, make sure we pair our characters though stay
locked Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got Altered.
Oh, no.
You Alter.
Yeah, me Alter.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're on the B tier bang.
Yep.
Yeah.
And then Valk.
Don't worry.
We have six games to do this.
I played in a Japanese VTuber tournament the other month.
Well, that's all I'm saying.
Oh.
We're good.
What placement?
Resorts good.
Six actually.
Oh, that's pretty good.
And we won a game.
Yeah, we won a game.
Yeah, yeah.
But did you get killed?
is well i think i got some okay resort resort where's valk
where's alter i don't even know what my character i don't
even know where all day oh there you are the first one yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've done a default balor skin look our name
is wash ggs so like my default altar skin too so like we got
this well this is good okay so me and doki are like you know
like uh like children running out and we'll bait them in
they're like well they don't have skins they're probably bad
yeah exactly they're exactly we're default enemies finish
you get them low and we kill them also like then you got
sheep then you got sheep yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll turn
on my aim bot real quick i'm like walling right now i see
people over there i see guys one guns are good oh we should
have talked about nine and g7 scout i heard are good you got
it r9 g7 scout oh re45 is not bad yeah re45 is an energy gun
right now uh it is that's a little burst a little burst
weapon not bad guys so is double mosaic still good oh yeah
you can rock that right now for sure 100 okay i'll be asking
a lot of these guns i should have like figured i should have
like landed here before my game before the tournament i'm
just like where is everything
star if you want to oh dude that sounds like everything can
i can run yeah i mean if you want there's not really that
many bad guns right now it's kind of the there are like the
best guns for sure yeah there's definitely like the best
weapons to use they're not about it but there's a g7 are she
is she seven again or nah oh there's two phoenixes here g7 i
thought that was pretty you can run the g7 that's good g7 is
better than like majority of other guns right now That's not
your best bet.
Alternator's not bad if you get the double tap perk.
There's a repeater here.
Is the repeater good?
Peter's good?
Yeah.
I feel like every gun I ask and just say it's good.
I'm putting R9s.
R9s, fantastic.
Okay, R9 is the best one.
Oh god, I got a hop up.
I got the hop up thing.
I have a mag if you have an R9.
Just let me know.
Yep, I got an R99.
And I got a mag.
Amazing.
Oh, you're killing it.
I'm like having less and less confidence with WIG because
he's like every gun we've said you're like yeah, that's good
That's a good gun like is there no bad guns like I mean like
if you're taking like R301 like R301 I'm gonna say drop that
shit for sure.
What about a flat line?
I would say probably not the flat line flat line greater
than L star Yes, yes, sadly, I would say so.
Oh, no
if you want that too there's a barrel stabilizer here okay i
ping the purple backpack if you guys don't have a purple
it's all the way over here the barrel stabilizers don't even
fit on the r99 anymore no it's a laser sight now yeah oh
we're getting there we go we're doing it we're doing i think
the easiest question is like what gun is not good um i mean
again like all three ones pretty bad for sure okay i'm flat
knight r99 i'm sticking with them All right, I'm taking, I'm
doing double light.
This might be the worst decision of my life, but I'm going
double light.
Low keep can be a good one, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Craft it whatever you need to, if you need like extra
battery or something.
All right, wait, where do we go?
Where do you think, you've watched so many of these games.
Where do you think it's end zone?
We need evos, no?
We need me.
Moxie, can you open this assault pin over here?
This little red bin over here?
Okay, yeah, I'm coming.
Yeah, come open that bad boy up.
I did not think I'd be this bad.
purple backpack and guess you're still on white i'm a little
worried oh no we're fine all right we got blue don't you
can't you upgrade to uh i can ring our survey what do you
want you definitely need to do the console ring for sure
okay wait we're gonna find a spot to go hit that bad boy i
might get hit it right now listen no that's not a survey oh
never mind i can't hit that right now we're gonna go to city
hall we're gonna go to city hall what is my upgrade is the
smoke one you could do that what's the other one again uh
damage to enemy alt and destroys enemy tack so that one's
better in the late game if you want to be more selfish you
choose the hp regen if you want to do a team playing style
then you probably do the other one for sure yeah are you a
team player can you just tell the pro here yeah pick that
pick the non-selfish one asshole how about that one dude
okay yeah i thought you were gonna be i thought you'd be
heal yourself only yourself yeah you get you heal us but
it's like dude like point three health every like i don't
know 38 seconds it's awful it's terrible all right we're
gonna go to city all and hit this beacon for the zone what
if i get shot but then i mean run for the hills dude i don't
say why has no one died yet um because that's called apex
competitive that's why yeah i like he fucking hate that for
us though it's okay what what if i get shot competitive
lobby then if i get around i'm gonna fucking crash out i
mean i'm covering you we're good we're good i don't think
anyone lived here i need us oh i mean someone landed here no
somebody no they landed here i know okay i swear to god if i
get shot i mean i'm so sorry if you do but this is what it
is
right now okay cover me yeah you're good you're good cover
me oh look how good you are look how good you are dude i'm
looking over you for sure oh my god this is a that's a weird
oh no okay it's going right to heights easiest end game
possible this yep upgrade yourself we're gonna go yeah yeah
hey guys i'm gonna keep it a buck it's very concerning that
i don't i have an hcog no i have the i have the circle scope
i need the one with the dot okay oh here here here take it
here here here here we need you so bad bro i'm also lagging
crazy so oh no guys i have a feeling when i die first i i
don't know it's just like crazy whoa whoa whoa whoa no we
got a high cold game we're getting an end game this is good
okay cool cool cool yeah yeah yeah i just i don't know
saying people are saying upgrade your What does that mean?
Oh, it's too late.
It's too late.
Yeah, too late.
Chad, why the fuck would you tell him that, man?
Yeah.
Why didn't you tell him like, like in the, in the past?
Oh.
You should predict the future.
All right.
We're going to go and hit this little survey beacon inside
Erdeg.
I'm lagging my ass off.
So this is a horrible start for us.
Plug in your controller.
The aim assist can't be lagged.
You can't lag when you have aim assist.
She's right.
Yeah, I'm right.
I'm just making excuses.
I'm not even lagging, man.
Wait, okay, we're left.
We're good.
I don't know where they are.
We're fine.
I'm going to hit this beacon.
We can just operate that way.
Yeah, we're fine.
Oh, there's a team in front.
There's a team in front.
There's a team right here.
Yeah, come back to me.
Come back to me.
Come this way to me.
We're going to navigate backwards.
Just keep up and right.
I fell down.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
We're so safe.
We're going to keep dodging all the bullshit, dude.
Okay.
so they're saying upgrade is they're talking about this oh i
just lagged out no we're good no no you're good you're good
you're good oh no no you're good you're still moving on my
screen all right come to me we're gonna ult you can be there
to zone okay there we go we're gonna get a little bit deeper
we're gonna land safe and we're gonna wait for another ulti
okay that's what we're gonna do i believe i should be able
to scan everybody here i'm lagging crazy so my fight's not
bad there's no scans going up oh they're they're here yep oh
there's a team here here for showing right here yep just get
on in here we're good to go for right now we're gonna play
right here we're gonna wait for there could be on our right
right now so here on the right side they are here they are
here i hit one for 108.
oh i hit one for not we're good you're good you're good
you're good i'm okay i had nothing oh no you don't worry all
good everything is flat I feel like a play far away.
Oh, yeah.
No, far away is definitely not.
Definitely not.
Flat line far away?
Um, I would say so.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Fall line far away is not bad.
Cover in our backs just in case.
Yeah, look that way.
Look that way.
I'm looking that way.
Should I get a hemlock instead?
I mean, if you want to, flat lines are a little bit better
than hemlock for sure.
I think we're going to go to the right side.
He's just there.
We're good.
We're chilling.
We're fine.
Okay.
I'll just be in behind this.
I'm feeling less confident when you say that, but okay.
Oh, no, we're so good.
don't trust me we're actually kind of robbing i think this
is monsoon no joke so okay so we just guys i got a quick
question do you guys hold on to right click and shoot or do
you tap it and then it zooms in um i hold hold hold yeah i
hold as well i'm just watching these guys trying to push it
on the southwest side yep just keep looking that way in that
way now yeah we're good i'm gonna we're gonna valve hold you
when i get it back in like 40 i have alt excel i have alt
excel okay i'll take that actually it'll be really good for
us w where the hell is this human holy What is going on?
What the fuck is going on for you?
I don't know.
I'm lagging so bad.
This is nuts.
I wonder if anyone else is lagging.
Just a me thing.
Oh, I hope it's not.
I hope someone.
I hope a team dies.
So we're not last.
So then I'll be okay with dying.
That's actually so true.
Fuck me, man.
Someone please fucking die.
This team died.
It's not me.
All right, guys.
Come over here to me real quick.
Come crawl through this little crouch area.
We're good.
We're gonna go to this building over here.
All right.
Why do I have a, why do I get movement speed?
Oh, it's a, it's a speed booster mantle boosting.
There you go.
Or if you're actually looking at us.
What?
Mantis boost.
There's a blue backpack here.
You pick it up.
Yeah, you get that blue.
I saw you.
All you.
Yep.
Got it.
Vibin.
Gray comms.
Okay, I'm, I'm chilling.
I'm so chill right now.
We're gonna wait for this zone to close and we're gonna find
out where we're going here, too.
I feel so chill.
I'm looking behind us to see anyone else's.
Oh, they're...
Yeah, they're moving up.
Chris, we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
All right.
You guys stay there and keep shooting those guys.
Okay.
I didn't shoot any shots.
Yeah, if you want to, go for it.
Up to you.
We're going to wait for the zone to close.
Oh, I thought I was trying to, I was trying to peek out my
window.
Oh, you gave them cover?
You gave them cover?
That's good.
Yeah, move to me.
Move to me real quick.
Come on.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, you're good.
That's good.
You're chilling.
We're gonna go in this building right here.
We're good to go.
I'm not lagged out.
Never mind, I'm still here.
No, you're still here.
You're still here.
I see you moving.
We're fine.
I don't know why I'm lagging so much, but shout out to 100
of these compound.
You guys are sick.
I'm gonna hit this beacon real quick once again.
We're making a risky play.
All right, we're good.
Move up to this next one for me.
Get over here to this next one.
We're going to top four.
Top four big building.
Yep, yep.
I'm on my way.
Follow me.
Yes, sir.
It's still 20 teams.
What's three?
Yeah, a lot of teams alive.
A little scary.
A little scary there.
Just a little bit.
A little nerve wracking, but we should be fine.
We're going to Valco D again when you guys get up here.
I'm here.
We're both here.
All right.
I'm lagging again.
We're good.
I'm trying to do my...
Moxie, Moxie, get over here.
Get over here.
Bro, you get shot.
We're good.
All right.
Stay on with me.
Don't go anywhere.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
There's a team over there.
I'm lagging horribly.
Oh, my God.
I'm lagging everywhere.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
We're good.
Stay here.
Come here.
Right on my spot.
My spot.
That's definitely monsoon.
This is not a bad spot.
We just need to play small.
Smoke when we can and we're good to go.
Yeah, yeah.
Beautiful.
Why the fuck am I lagging so much?
Yeah, no, you know, when I was like, I have a feeling.
We're good.
Okay, okay.
You guys better say something than nothing.
You know what I had?
I was like, how the fuck are there 20 teams alive, bro?
What the fuck is going on?
Everyone.
Everyone's trying to play zone.
Should I open up this assault bin?
If you want to, don't go.
and then open it.
Yup, yup, yup.
I'm lagging again.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Put someone on me close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, right about us.
We're good.
I'm looking at them.
We're showing.
Alright, stay here real quick.
I need you to some recon real fast.
You guys stay here.
Okay, just don't lag while you're reconning.
Just don't lag when you're reconning.
Wait, we're not last.
Guys, guys, we're not last.
We can die.
No, we're good.
We're good.
I'm lagging so bad.
This is fucking insane.
What has happened?
Oh, Smokey G.
I get my Valkaldi back.
This could be very good for us.
Could be very good.
I'm trying to see if I can poke.
There's like a fight right here.
Okay, what we're going to do here is we're going to, when I
get Valkaldi back, which I should, we're going to smoke the
height building and then we're going to Valkaldi block their
LOS.
Okay, so yeah, Moxie, the smoke, it depends on you.
Okay, well, say again, say you smoke one.
I'm top here when I tell you to.
On that.
Okay, on top of there.
What do I tell you?
No, you will.
You will.
We were good though.
Not yet.
How long did my smoke last?
Five seconds.
You'll be good.
I'll tell you what.
Don't stress it.
You're good.
Okay.
There is a team below us right here.
Yes.
There should be a lot of teams dying here.
When do I bangles?
I'll tell you when as well.
Not yet.
On her right, we're good.
People are moving up on us kind of.
We're fine.
Underneath us as well.
We're good.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Super slow.
Nice, nice.
All right.
I think you missed it.
All good.
Come here, come here, here.
Oh, yeah.
No worries.
Okay, we have really nowhere to go.
Oh, so we're just going.
This is really bad.
Bottom up?
You're right here.
Go here.
Yeah, here, here, here, here.
All right, here we go.
How do we fight?
Smok, smoke, smoke, smoke, smoke, smoke.
Oh shit, it's bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Everyone's fighting us.
Keep moving.
He's smoking.
He's doing what he can.
Nice.
I wanna how we're alive.
How we're alive.
I'm just put this right here so we can like, I don't know.
I'm killing two because why not?
Right in front of us.
Can knocks.
We're good.
I'm thirsty.
I thirsted him.
We're good, we're good.
I got smoke and 10.
Yep, yeah, sir.
This...
We're good.
Just kill him whatever you can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm cool down, soldier.
I'm cool down.
Okay, I'm feeling it.
I feel like we're good though.
I can feel we're good.
I can hold it.
Yeah, hold it.
Just hold it until we get shot at and then like pray.
Yeah, late game, late game.
We're going, we're going here.
Late game.
We're going to the other side.
Oh my god.
I got body block.
I got one.
I got killed.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Good job.
I didn't get the full.
I got full kill.
We got full kill.
We got point.
We got one point.
Nice.
Big points.
One point, guys!
Come on, guys.
Great job.
Okay.
There's a...
Oh, wait, I got most...
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna shake that, actually.
Wait, can I finish this?
Like, can I finish people off or down?
Did I get the kill?
No, no.
Only if you knock them, but it doesn't matter.
I think you still do it.
You still do it regardless.
Okay.
There's a double.
This is her.
Yep, yep.
Oh, oh.
This is crazy, dude.
Yeah, this is...
I'm a little scared.
No, late game, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
Oh, my God!
Yeah, cut to me.
Cut to me.
We're fine.
We're good.
Oh, Nate.
Nate.
I don't feel fine.
We're fine.
We're good.
We're healthy.
We're Gucci.
We're so Gucci, bro.
I'm so healthy.
We're this trap.
Break this trap.
Shoot that shit out.
Fuck it.
Oh, they all threw us.
They all threw us.
Yeah, yeah, you're good.
You're good.
Oh my god.
What is fucking happening?
It's okay, it's okay Stick sticks and stick Come to me.
We're gonna hold you.
Come here.
Come here Okay.
I'm one inch, but okay Oh my god Where we going?
Where we going?
I have no idea.
There's nowhere to go What do we go?
maybe go here go here go here go here oh no yeah not yet not
yet do not rest don't you know res yet okay okay you're so
good so good how are we alive though what the fuck yeah I
mean I'll calculate it it's obviously calculated dude I knew
that was gonna happen inside that.
But I need you to body block me.
We're good.
We need to get in here.
I can't move up.
I got a smoke.
You gotta smoke.
Smoking, smoke it.
Get in here, get in here.
Oh my god.
I'm in there so soon.
No!
I'm not.
I couldn't.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm so healthy.
I'm a smallcy honest.
Hipsy, hop, hop, hop, hop.
Hit it, hit it.
90, 90.
It's okay.
So you could maybe potentially...
Give me shield, give me shield.
He's right here.
He's right on your windows.
I'm so dead.
Mother suckers.
What the fuck?
All I'm saying is that you falconed me into the zone when I
was one.
Dude, I was lagging.
Guys.
Yeah.
Did they send the right code?
I feel like I'm in the ALGS here.
What the fuck was that?
why were there so many teams alive look yes i all i'm seeing
is i could have lived no all i'm saying is the fact that we
just got top 10 with no defensive character and that was
ridiculous that was nuts that was crazy unreal holy fuck me
that was awesome great game we got top 10 and a kill dude
that was good yeah yeah we got one no point we got two
points i think two points that's not bad at all yeah yeah
okay so and 50 was just you dokey yeah exactly i got the 50
of those points and then the rest was a team effort yep
exactly what that was yeah that's all one man there's
straight team efforts i feel like we do eight shots office
what the is going on with this we should just run at a team
not gonna lie no i mean we probably should next time i think
we're better than majority the squad yeah let's just run out
of team yeah we got these people i think so too i think we
can do it yeah we can do it i don't want to fight in this
tiny ass zone dude fuck those fucking stanky fucking costly
players too man yeah isn't it costing why am i not lagging
watching what is going on oh yeah my bad i didn't tell you
to bang all that's my fault oh yeah he never banged oh yeah
We could have had a bang on Could have had a bang on people
for sure 100% totally try to tell you to do that zombie I
feel like ulti doesn't work for this No, not really I mean
if we're gonna run at people it'll work We just need to run
at people Yeah, maybe Yeah We need a good job though Like I
can't move we say a lot for so long Yeah, we did I didn't
know when to use the queue Cause I feel like if we queue I
would we would die Whoa, I should have ulted the bus, huh?
Yeah, probably Yeah It's all good I should have told you to
do that I should have told you to do that to be fair No
worries you know what I'm gonna use use stuff without you
having to say it I like that my own thinking I kind of like
that out of you I think you should do that I'll trust you I
trust you entirely oh sort of maybe I used it under to the
bridge when we got shot at maybe no cuz it wouldn't hit them
anyway cuz the bridge is bridge I think maybe you should
restart your game too I don't know if I'm thinking yeah
let's say it was I'm gonna ask that real quick I mean,
people, some people are restarting, I think.
Oh, wait, I think every, yeah, everyone was lagging.
Okay, okay, cool.
What I say, man, hard to be a really good runner.
Or pingy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, they said everyone was lagging.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to restart the game regardless, though, real
quick.
Oh, yeah.
I'll get the new code anyway.
Just in case.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
What the fuck?
My ping is so high for that, Siri.
Yeah, I'm having a hundred.
120 on east why'd you invite me i'm east coast okay that's
crazy that was a bad server yeah we'll chop it up to the
server god damn you yeah i wouldn't have got knocked in zone
if it wasn't for the server no exactly all
right not our faults not our faults it was this you know
what they should might as well just like they might as well
just god even count the first game you know warm-up yeah
yeah that should just be a warm-up game for everyone
bad server create entertainment I feel like Loki we could
just run at some squads yeah I think let's do it let's do it
for next game let's just run at run at people I'm down I'm
down all right my steam is updating dude I'm gonna literally
never mind I'm not they can't be updating mid game dude come
on man bad valve by the way no so I don't know what you're
gonna play i mean rife maybe portals is valke even that
broken i mean i mean all the rotations we got was because of
valke did she just see what she just did for us dude oh yeah
well i don't know the value of that it just looked like i
was going on the trip oh yeah we're on like worldwide all
right here's the new lobby code
we're back oh yeah we are I was like, Valc is also the
reason why you died in the zone, to be fair.
Yeah, that is true.
I would agree with that.
Valc did take me to my death.
Do people not run Gibby anymore?
No.
Okay.
I think it's because there's Newcastle's just better.
Oh,
you guys are tapped in.
Hey, listen.
Top 10 for us was very surprising there.
Yeah, me too.
I was very surprised.
You know what?
You should really...
yeah go back and look what i was dealing with on that flight
that was no i felt it no i felt it on my yeah no we felt
that i felt that there was a lot of turbulence there i
thought we were gonna die i thought i was gonna be on that
like the the plane crash documentary series uh all right All
right, I'm loading back in now.
Hopefully this won't work.
Okay, I got worried because I thought you were lagging.
Sounded like you were lagging.
I'm sure I should be fine.
I'm unplugging the gigantic light, dude.
This Nate shot office needs a fucking revamp.
You saw that room at money, brother.
Get this.
You're in Nate shot's office right now?
Yeah, I'm taking over.
Bro, why don't you challenge me?
I'm gonna start with the slots in the pregame.
He allowed you?
Oh, yeah, always, dude.
I know you broke in.
Oh, you guys are tied like that.
Oh, yeah.
be tight brother is that your christmas bonus streaming in
the nade shot office yeah i'm gonna steal the nike shoes he
has in here too and everything else i bet he has a lot of
shoes you won't notice it right he actually does have so
much in here that he just did not take when he moved from
california i don't understand he has his youtube one million
black in here you don't want that in your house like i don't
understand bro he has too many maybe he has like a
collection yeah well he has an x games gold medal over there
too he doesn't
like that'd be my bra i would brag about that every day in
my life that's insane they just they just not show up like
that i guess so man fuck me yeah i get like my boy yeah you
just has too many that's such a humble brag like he's like
yeah they're not that important dude literally if i play
16th at x games shout out to your rule probably says like
the the gold weighs too much or like oh maybe he's oh maybe
he's investing in the gold you know he's waiting to the gold
value shots up so then he can melt it so that's why he
leaves in his office that he doesn't go to yeah it's a
long-term gain instead of like a safe or a vault yeah he
heard the ramsticks are going up and you know what ramsticks
need cold yeah well you're thinking you're thinking here
Yeah, I'm thinking there.
So what are you going to play now, Wig?
We're going to run at people.
Uh-oh.
Wig?
I think he stands up to go touch some gold.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe he's trying to steal the gold right now.
Something like that.
Okay.
This is, okay.
I honestly think like, yeah.
Like, I feel like we did get unlucky positioning.
Like, yeah, no, we did.
to a rooftop like well i mean we're running at people we
don't need to go get into positioning we're just killing
people down also they banned g7 g7 scout band yeah oh oh
my god you're right he's being a hundred thieves literally
where
did we go so wait we got weapon bands too is that what
they're saying g7 scout is banned now oh thank god oh yeah
they didn't want to see me on that Didn't run over five of
those.
Start the game.
We're ready.
R.
Let's do it.
If I lag this time around, I'll be so sad.
You lag.
Just say you crashed and de-matter restart.
You're so smart.
Just leave the game.
I'll start betting some rules.
You know what the fuck?
Why not?
You're literally the apex legends.
Thanks, man.
I appreciate that.
Even though you just literally called me dog shit for like
three and a half hours before.
no it's called tough love it makes you stronger i'm trying
to give you motivation to prove me wrong it's actually so
nice to you yeah see you're gonna be like i'm not dog i'm
gonna prove her wrong and then obviously that didn't work
but don't worry in the second game i'll work we got two
points though we had to be at least top 15 leaderboard um i
mean game one is still in progress so i'm oh i guess they're
like subtracting all the kills from the other people but
it's okay you didn't get a kill so like you don't have to
work on our team
i mean at least i didn't get that kp there yeah yeah i got
it it was me i believe in moxie too and getting a kill on
the last yeah i did some damage there yeah yeah i'm
surprised you stayed alive dude the smokes and they were so
good yeah i appreciate that They were so good.
You like that discipline I had when I said I'm not going to
smoke?
I went against the call.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
You went against the IGL.
Yeah.
A piece of shit.
God.
Because it saved our lives because you went against it.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
The camera call wasn't the right call.
That's what I respected.
You know what I mean?
Don't look at the smokes in the mountains.
the worst people there they wouldn't have been able to snipe
us though did you did you really miss both of those up top
no he did yeah i was like don't look back don't look back
that was that was a hell mary oh hey so no balk no balk okay
i'm gonna go i mean i could go do you want me to be
defensive character or rotational characters look at you
guys i want to run at teams i'll stop play wraith look all
right and we're gonna die in our first encounter but i want
it's fine oh wait wait wait wait that's not true okay we're
gonna make it but like do i try like i know we want to rent
teams but like if i do that do i go for the kp and just say
yeah just say don't worry trusted moxie in me okay then you
have to trust in me right yeah yeah guys where do we where
do we know where someone's dropping um well there's teams
around us all around us i know that they all have drop spots
around us yeah we're like a very uh very good pli but
everybody else around us is pretty good ones too yeah shout
out to effect i asked him where to go and he gave out of
effect yeah shout out to him great guy honestly great kid
i'm not logging right now lagging right now logging your log
okay you're logging into your hacks right now you're that
one fuck me because i feel like if we run someone down we
get blue armor boom suck they're done exactly i like the
confidence out of y'all just don't be disappointed if we get
shit on you know what i mean oh no g7 oh fuck what about my
g7 we like we're gonna get shit on yours that's why we have
you here yeah that's why we have you yeah no thanks for sure
obviously yeah you're the one that's gonna help us right
yeah thank you guys so much man 100 alternator prowler i got
the attachment
um i would probably say the prowler bro i can't lie yeah
wait the attachment it's white though i don't think i have
it oh yeah no no you gotta earn it oh what you gotta get
damage up brother we gotta get some damage up game he's just
like what the i earned it it's gotta earn his fucking
proudly oh you gotta earn that back here all right well
these servers look so good right yeah yeah for sure i'm
lagging again i'm lagging i'm lagging or or or flatline oh
it's really just reference to yeah okay let's go on you
should look at all the guns first this guy bro actually then
gets mad at the ass bro geez louise all right we're good i'm
ready peter all right none yep is neminus still good or bad
wig i mean it's all right i wouldn't say it's like the best
but people still use it okay i'll just use you have like no
but i don't think you do it all right i'm gonna get this evo
cash for us and then yeah and then i'll yeah well we're
gonna do that might as well get the ring cancel okay look
down bro who's here man why are you looking at me you bum
they're gaked they're camping our evo cash these freaks ew
that's stinky brother that's so no g7 scout i can't pick one
up nope no don't pick it up we get banned immediately okay
so alternator better than the r301 uh i would say say Maybe.
It depends if we're going to get the attachment or not.
We're already, anyway.
We're over on the bridge right now.
I want to get the evo cash, but they're kind of gatekeeping
us.
They're freaks.
I got one of...
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Bro, they better not gatekeep us, because then we're going
to have to fight them for sure.
But I want that blue armor first.
I think everybody wants to...
He's fighting now.
Not last.
I did 63 on two of them.
So I don't really know whether they're still gatekeeping us,
bro.
These freaks leave.
i'm a headless chicken right now no cap yeah one on this
roof right here the one over our bridge i don't know where
roof went we've got a meta dipped and they're over left side
now we might be able to get the evo cash we definitely want
to get it so we can get the beacons and stuff yeah if you
can get it that'd be great i'm covering i'm covering for you
look it over you as well yeah i got two smokes yeah you
should be good you should be good They're far left now.
Yeah, they're rotating.
They're rotating.
You're five.
All right.
I'll go do a ring beacon.
Survey.
I'll do survey.
I'm going to come with you because I think they might be
playing for our beacon.
It's the only reason I can think they're over here.
So they might be coming back to fight us, Doki.
We'll see.
We'll see if I get shot at.
I hope not.
I'm here with you.
So we'll see what happens.
I'll put a portal down for me, B.
I think we're fine.
I don't think I need a portal.
No, I'm just saying that's the case.
There you go.
team let's run these guys down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were down.
I want to fight them.
Which one?
Let's do it.
I don't even know what rider left.
South side.
This way.
This way, this way.
I'm coming.
Yep.
Fuck it.
Let's do it, man.
Do it!
Not last!
Not last.
Fuck it.
Yeah, better as well.
I'm looking over.
I'm with Moxie.
Up here.
Garage, garage.
Garage.
I'm playing topside garage.
Oh, they have high ground.
Okay, that's not good.
Should chase?
Should've chase?
We could.
They jumped off.
I know they're still there.
Still there.
Let's go there.
Buffy Boxy.
I'm ulting.
Jumping.
Nice.
I'm 1, I'm 1.
I'm batting and I'm running.
Oh, they're running charge rifle.
Yeah, this is a rampart.
Oh, do I kind of do damage to myself?
Oh my God, I'm going to kill myself.
I put a portal down to get a little aggressive, but I can't
really do much on that.
I'm trying to see right now though.
Oh, God.
I'm putting a...
I'm fucking out.
It's okay.
You're fucking out.
You're good.
this is awful that's the worst part i broke his wall though
we should get out of here yeah they're playing loki's i
think we do get out there's a terrible fight i got him so
low too that sucks yeah we got one one hp oh man i altered
myself i didn't know i could take damage to myself what the
i was killed to myself yeah yeah now you know now you don't
now you don't now you don't sorry i think that was a big
Yeah, a while ago, a while ago.
I don't remember that.
All good, all good.
We're just gonna wait for see what these guys do, because we
need to move.
See, are they still over there?
Bums now.
They're there.
All right, we're gonna move up.
Let's go to bridge over here.
Watch out with this other team that was kind of lurking near
us.
I got no bats, by the way.
I'm gonna look at that again, dude.
These fucking assholes, man.
Thank you for the thingy.
They're like just staring at us.
Oh, I gotta read the play.
I gotta read the play.
Yeah, I did too.
But what do these guys do if they want to fight them down?
But they're gonna see.
Yeah.
They're playing like rampart, not trying to fight, but
fight.
I hit 160.
It's fucking assholes, dude.
Back up.
Yeah, you're like, oh, and they threw.
They're getting on bridge now.
This is bad.
Yeah, they have.
Might have to take a portal.
Yeah, portal.
This is really bad actually.
Yeah, I'm going to have to put out.
I'm going to put out here too.
I'm going to go left and try to get angles for us.
Yeah, they're looking at us.
They're like definitely want to fight us.
I'm lagging again.
Oh, no.
Give me a sec.
I should be about if I went this.
pulling down you guys need to take it immediately okay we're
here we're here i would take i would take i'll take i'll
take they're on us on me yep this is bad actually smoke
again smoke again move up a little bit move up a little bit
okay we're good we're good yeah move up move up up up okay
okay they're looking at me they're looking at me they're
looking at me i need a about that too as well i can't see
them i don't know where they are i'm so far gone i don't
know where they are okay i see them okay i'm going i'm going
up okay they're looking at me they're looking at me they're
looking at me i'm trying to look at you i'm trying to look
at you good i'm This one got me right here.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't want to be left off.
You're good.
I'm coming back to you guys You're good.
You're 142.
I have two on you.
I have two on me Yeah, I crafted a little on the left.
So rampart to snare me They're kind of swinging me a little
bit, but we're fine right now.
How do I keep I need?
I'm running.
I'm running right the ring way the ring way.
Yeah, the ring way I love it.
Yeah, the ring way I love Yeah, but if you can I have the
healing I have to play slow so get try to get that full kill
if you can first I don't even know where you got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
They moved up here.
Southwest side.
We're good.
They're playing concession stand.
They're running away now.
They're scared.
Great fucking knock.
Good job.
I'm going to grab their meds.
I'm grabbing your meds.
Yeah.
I got no shield cells.
I will use them.
Yeah.
I'll take some of those.
I used everything as well.
So take those for sure.
I got you.
They're still fighting me, bro.
Back up, brother.
I just want to wait.
Did your ass leave?
I have a kill if you guys want to use it.
Oh, my God.
We need to get the zone.
Wait, they're geeking me.
I swear here.
Left side.
Down, down, down.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
Boxing.
I guess what the fuck was that?
He just bodied me.
Wait, is that a different team?
Wait, this is a different team.
This is a different team.
It has to be.
Has to be.
Yeah, no, it is a different team.
Moxie.
It's a different team.
Boxing.
Oh, my God.
Can we go into portal?
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
It's all right.
Run, run, run, run.
You're good.
Yeah, run upside and then maybe craft up.
If you need to take your TP back, you might be playing zone.
No, I will 100%.
It'll be in zone.
Maybe you can play it if you need to.
I don't have enough meds for it.
No meds?
How many guys?
I have syringes and two med kits.
Most of it is just that.
Okay, I think you go, I think you craft us here maybe then.
Yeah?
If you can, you take, yeah, because the zone's kind of
close.
I don't think you're going to get anywhere else.
You got this, I believe in you.
wrapped into zip lunch confidence what is the oh wait i
heard something wait where is the craft there's gonna be one
out here for sure it's right here everybody i don't think
you get the a beacon though it sucks no but you may be
finding a respawn somewhere the close one's 330 never mind
and i could try to go for this one yeah it just depends how
many heals if you can find any more while you're sitting
here too yeah i don't know if i I can find more syringes.
Yeah, I might be a little bit tough.
I'll loot it up.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's not great.
I don't see any syringes.
I heard shots from my right.
Yeah, I think you just keep going left personally.
Yeah.
Get the fuck away from these guys.
I literally hear shots.
Oh, I hear shots here too.
One more.
Hit your finder.
One more placement.
All I'm saying is no points.
Oh.
I only have syringes after this.
ranges.
You got this, you got this.
Turn that building to right.
What's up?
I'm just going to try and look at behind that rock, maybe.
Yeah.
If you can rotate and lift, this might be your best shot,
but I don't know.
I don't know if I can get that Riz off.
That's a thing.
I don't know.
So I don't think you can either.
No, I don't know.
You definitely can.
Is there anywhere safe that you can play, like, ratting for
the rest of the game?
I'm trying to think.
Are you not in zone here, right?
No.
I did.
Yeah, it's tough.
Yeah, it's flashing.
That sucks.
There was another team.
Bro, that was my bad.
I greeted the guy who downed.
I was like, dude, this guy's cooked.
It was not cooked.
Bro, we had a armada.
No, I'll talk to him in.
I'm going to throw...
I can throw my ult right here.
I mean, you're safe there, by the way, behind that rock.
You're inside.
But then yeah, but I'm sure they're gonna spot you though.
Yeah, they're gonna spot me.
They're gonna look around.
If you go forward, they're gonna kill you regardless, even
if you queue.
Yeah.
Um, the best thing is I throw my ult right here and then
just hope for the best.
Tor, why is no one dying?
I hate it.
I know.
What the fuck?
I bet I'm gonna be the 16 squad.
I can feel it.
This is so crazy.
What the?
Wait, what?
That's Moxie Smoke.
Rings me behind.
Wait, wait, wait.
So land, it just landed now?
It just landed now, dude.
I would not throw that, Duggy.
They're going to 100% hear you.
No, what if?
If you put that down and you get that off, I will be
mind-blowing.
What if?
You're so close to sound.
This sucks.
What if I just throw it?
If you throw that and they don't shoot you, I will literally
be mind-blowing, dude.
I think that was the...
What is that throw?
Okay, and then I go left, so they think I go over.
Oh my god!
The strat is that...
You did it, you did it, you're good.
You're good, you're so good.
Wait, you actually might get top 10.
You're good.
What a fucking horrible throw that was.
We won't talk about it.
Rachel, I want a play.
Yeah, 50!
I'm a beautiful job.
15 plays.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
We did it, guys!
We're 15 plays!
14, 14.
10 if you literally just walk in the zone as low as possible
13 13 13 13 you're the only person playing without a team
don't say that you really got this okay if someone goes from
this way they'll shoot my portal first so i'll be notified
that's the strat i put it out in the open i put it in the
open so i know if someone's pushing me on my left see see
wait that's a big
Guys, I would love to add to this conversation.
I have no idea what your old does That's okay.
No, I mean dude, you're adding to it.
You know what I mean by saying that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah So now so basically basically it's a
great dialogue It's a tp so I can go back to it if I need
to.
Okay.
Now I see the potential.
Yeah.
Your play is good then Definitely don't go back to it though
They shut out who cares.
Fuck him.
They might know you're here now though Fuck these guys.
I know dog shit okay I'll throw another one here yeah yeah
for sure yeah but when the zone top 12 top 12 if you really
just walk in with this zone this could be the play but you
might get top 10 again okay you also don't have a MOB
correct I want to want to make sure that's 100% I have a
readable I could read a play I mean we're fighting no
they're not I'm not about to you so sorry yeah I know I Play
your game, play your game.
That's all you do.
Yeah, what the fuck?
Oh my god, do you think they notice?
They noticed.
No, you're good.
Yeah, you're chilling, dude.
Yeah, no, they noticed.
Not bad.
Not bad, dude.
We'll take it.
Dude, we'll take it.
Dude, I can't believe they noticed.
Yeah.
Maybe you should have popped that Hive Ag tower.
I knew it.
I told you.
I was like, dude, I think I should Evac Tower, bro.
I told you I should have Evac.
Dude, this is such a sweaty comp.
Ash caustic lifeline.
My god, they want to win that.
We couldn't fucking.
I can't believe we couldn't fucking run at teams.
Everyone didn't want us to run at them.
I know.
What the hell was that about?
Why is everyone running away from us?
I know.
They didn't tell me to watch GGs.
Oh my god, they got caustic ulted.
all but no no not oh wait wait they're good wait oh they
have the yeah yep the halo that's gigantic it's a great play
out of them actually wait so what should we play then yeah
should i just run lifeline that's up to you guys yeah it's
up to you but you're the idea wig i don't think altar's good
but you seem like you really want to alter but i was the
last one to live true but does it have to do with altar or
are you running away no no that's too multi i think it has
to do with us feeding oh that's true that's true us yeah no
yeah i mean we we're teamier it's a team game wig it's a
team game feed there yeah i know for a fact that moxie heard
that's a new team at least five times i know for a fact dude
okay but i didn't know he's our tier three player yeah and
i'm the Did it cancel?
Did you thirst it?
Yeah, you got it.
Okay, you got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, guys, I'll be honest.
The one thing that's really, like, my biggest hindrance
right now is knowing where people are.
Like, half the time, like, you say, like, there's people, I
have no idea where they are.
I'll get better comms of, like, you know, the southwest.
You need a ping more.
You need a ping.
I don't need one ping.
I need spams.
No, for sure.
I'll spam it.
I'm going to communicate in southwest 196.
You know what I mean?
I'll say all that.
Okay.
because I'm lost in that way, because I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, he's a tier 3 player.
He doesn't, like, understand the game like you, Whig.
Oh, yeah, for sure.
100%.
It's more so, you know, like, we don't got, we don't got any
scan characters.
It's hard to keep up with the fights.
It's difficult.
Yeah, but USC IGL should tell us that, you know?
True, my bad.
Yeah.
Again, yeah, my fault, correct.
Your job is to lead us.
And I don't feel the leading part yet.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You felt the last game.
I know you did.
No, I know you did.
I felt the last game.
Yeah, yeah.
The last game I felt it.
I was a commander in action.
What happened to the second game though?
It's like you like checked out.
Well, one of our game play was a fight and no one wanted to
smoke.
Whoa.
So you're blaming Moxie?
Wait, no, not us.
The other teams they want to fight.
So my smoke was bad.
Yeah, yeah.
You try to say, hey.
So you're saying I don't want to smoke us.
Yeah.
No, you had great smokes, man.
Okay, there we go.
Great smokes.
I think your smokes were so good that they didn't want to
fight us.
Oh, okay.
So they're like, well, these guys, this guy smokes too good.
Yeah, okay.
Massive boners.
This guy smokes fat boners.
Okay, so what should we play then?
Okay, I think personally, what defensive characters can you
cook up for us?
Well, I don't know.
Yeah, what kind of...
I don't even know what that word means.
So defensive, support.
Okay, like support, you know what I mean?
Give me some defensive characters.
Name some defensive characters.
Newcastle.
Yeah, I can do it.
I can do it.
Lifeline.
Lifeline's good.
That's not bad.
Gibby.
Yeah.
Okay.
So cook up a comp.
I've had a few games on Gibby in my time.
Yeah.
Cook up some comps for us.
Wig.
Yeah, I think like a Watson, Watson's really good.
Okay.
Okay, no one's confident on any of these characters right
now.
No, no, I am.
I am.
I just cook up some comps.
I need to know some comps right now.
Rafe, Watson, okay?
Bang, phenomenal.
Okay, I can do that.
I can do that.
So you can do Watson.
Yeah, I can do Watson.
Okay, are you okay on that?
No, what, what?
Okay.
How did we, how did you get there?
You were saying lifeline.
I said, I could put, like how hard, like, come on, it's
lifeline.
I put my E and then you get it here.
You got res, you Q when you get your heels.
So for Rafe, Watson.
And my old eye dropped down a care package.
Like, what's so bad about that?
So she got updated about three years ago.
So she doesn't have her care package anymore.
That actually might have been in 2021.
Okay, okay, okay.
So I don't know what, what do you mean put your E?
What do you mean by put isn't E?
What does that mean?
I don't even know.
Honestly, I don't even know what that means.
the second ability number what's what's the letter number
number what's the letter of it it's a no no okay i'm i'm
getting concerned i'm getting scared now wig i'm getting
scared we keep saying that though but he just got the one kp
yeah and i also got the one kp on the other game too i'm
gonna show you right now i'm learning oh it's cute yeah he's
like you could go to the practice range right now oh so the
z the z is this like shield thing yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think i could pick this if we need it yeah you think so okay
they bound yeah so what does he do they ban all two okay
altar great that's actually good for us Yeah, that's good
for us.
So your Z is like for Lifeline.
So I thought we were playing Bang.
Okay, you want me on Bang?
I'll play Bang.
Okay, so what's the comp?
Watson, Bang, and what?
Wait, you just need to say what we need to be on, all right?
Yeah.
That's all you got to say.
You got to, you call the boss moves.
You're the guy with the knowledge.
So I'm going to say it again.
And I want to, let me know if you hear, let me know if you
hear of Lifeline.
Okay, so Bang.
Okay, huh?
Watson No, not lifeline Now you're confusing us wing Are you
confusing us?
Do we play lifeline or not?
What are we doing?
Watson Yep Wraith Wraith Okay Are you writing this down
Moxie?
Are you like taking notes right now?
Lifeline Wraith Wraith?
Wraith?
Who is Wraith?
You said Wraith You just said dragon base.
I don't know what I'm saying right now.
I'll be honest I'm on a definite different dimension right
now with this game.
Okay, so we don't want Pathfinder Just making sure I just
feel like I didn't like my bangs haven't been Bangin like I
feel like I'm getting kills, but it's not because my
abilities Okay, so you think my smokes are good Yeah, but we
need the smokes to rotate though Okay, okay, I'll be
smoking.
All right.
There we go.
I can lifeline whichever one you want.
I feel like you really want to play lifeline.
If you want to play lifeline.
Do you?
I feel I just saw lifeline live that whole thing.
Res her teammates without even like just tapping them.
But the thing, the key is that you have to live to be able
to do all of that.
Can you sustain yourself enough to be able to do all that
instead of getting knocked first?
That's okay.
Yeah, you need to be like last alive type of thing.
of shit you know what i'm saying can you be last alive can
you be last alive okay i could i could play for i could play
for a little damage okay i could try so what does that mean
that's usually not okay i'm not a person that just like sits
i i have a hard time not wanting to go in but i can try to
reserve myself here oh okay so you're gonna restrain
yourself so you're gonna play lifeline okay so i can play
bang i could do bang so now we're not giving watson we're
doing lifeline bang We'll go back.
I'll go bank.
I feel like this is fucking Because you make it sound like
lifeline's a bad addition to bang lifeline and Wraith so
like it well, we can't do the addition because it's four.
That's four characters It would be it would be more of a
substitution.
Okay, so so what would you substitute lifeline for Watson?
um yeah Yeah, yeah Okay, I'll play bank.
Okay, so so Sorry, the cop is what's the captain's time wig
just to be sure what is the cop
Watson oh, yeah, right right okay.
Can you say that one more time just in case Bang rotson wait
rate rotson rotson rotson rons Rots ronson rod rate Watson
bang exactly.
Yep So you're playing bang Yep, as always, we're here.
As always, baby.
As always, we're locked, guys.
We're so locked in.
We're doing it, guys.
Let's go down.
Can I go find a guitar right now in this compound?
Someone's got one, though.
I'm going to go find one.
I'm going to go lock in.
Okay, we're going to do, we're going to be safe this time,
right?
I believe in us.
Do you believe in us, Moxie?
Come on.
Like, I feel like we're slowly getting, like, tapped in.
Like, I feel like we're building up.
We're getting better.
I mean, the second game we placed lower, but each game we're
getting better.
Yeah, no, these players ain't.
Like, who's winning these rounds?
Like, who's getting, who's first place right now?
First place team is team number four.
Okay.
I'll look these people up.
I'm going to take some notes on their, on their team.
You're going to look at their vibes.
Let's see what they're doing differently.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, this guy's on Hambino's team?
Dude, Hambino just owned me in a freaking tournament the
other day.
Oh, different way, Hambino.
I believe.
I believe in us.
Oh, actually, the first place team is...
I mean, they haven't calculated the second game yet, but
it's team 16.
That's first place from game one.
okay also all the teams that are better than us right now
they are pro players so you know we don't we don't really
have the pros you know we have wig our fellow fellow gamer
that's on mk that's our fellow apex streamer that's our
fellow apex streamer exactly
we should have gotten the pro then geez
believe in wig oh wig is not back yet wig is not back and we
are selecting a character oh oh oh no oh no oh no oh it's
okay he's on wraith so it should be fine i'm on watson okay
no roller in this whole facility wait were you actually
looking for a roller yeah oh my god wig i told you you keep
back you came crawling back to amuses i want to have some
fun dude were you roasting me the whole time i was no no of
course not moxie i wasn't roasting him right you were saying
uh we got this next games yeah i was like saying how i i
believe in nice wigs igl in the third game like we found our
characters and everything i believe in his guidance i feel
like we're loki sleeping on my pathfinder i think so i don't
know if it's good right now or I don't know.
Do you want to play?
Do you want to play it?
No, no, I'm good.
I'm just saying like, I feel like we're not really playing
as a team.
I feel like we should just be playing like as the best thing
that that enhances our own gameplay.
Okay, so they'll play pass or lifeline.
Wait, where's Watson?
Oh, there she is.
Are you going to go Pathfinder?
Are you?
Uh, no.
I feel like, okay.
You're just like, are you going to do it?
but my whole chat's saying path is meta i don't know i'm
getting baited right now but i feel like why would they lie
it's meta in their hearts okay but like moxie did you see a
single pathfinder when we were fighting those two games well
yeah the noobs are gonna i mean the noobs aren't gonna be
playing pathfinder you know yeah but did you see the any
pathfinders though while we were playing you got a point all
right i'm locking in so what's been g7 scout and havoc What
the fuck?
Oh shit, were people even playing that?
Oh, oh that's good.
Apparently I found a roller, one second.
Oh nice, nice, nice, nice, more time.
I made some calls.
Someone driving over, Uber eats a controller.
It's okay, I believe in us.
We got scrimmed, but I believe in us.
Someone crashed?
Everyone's here.
Why are people saying scrimps?
Oh, it's because it's an apex thing where in scrims, they
always end matches before the match starts.
Because someone will crash or something.
It's just like, it's just an apex thing.
Damn, I'm so not tapped in.
I gotta tap in.
I'm gonna try, it's like, okay, it's okay.
Moxie can pick path now.
Yeah, you know, I'm not gonna try anything.
fancy i believe it's okay we have four more games four more
games to experiment
yeah but then when then the games when we figure it out like
we only have that little games left yeah but then we're
gonna we're gonna drop a bomber we're gonna drop a nuke you
know on the the final game that we figure it out we're just
gonna kill the entire lobby because we figured it out right
yeah so why is everyone talking about my i've never been an
octane player guys like i was i've never been an octane
player i got one for next game we did it yeah this game i
know where it is we're good oh wait you know where it is
okay yeah apparently they got rid every fucking controller
in this goddamn million dollar facility why oh fucking no if
you look anywhere and find like 80 of them i'm out of breath
bro i was running around it's okay you're getting that blood
warmed up oh my god i'm out of breath dude bro how big is
this facility it's honestly huge items heal over time what
there is i have two blue backpacks near me okay so no one
uses shotguns not really right now no okay use kind of like
the the double mosaims but everything else is kind of not
good enough to go to check check check check check my weapon
enhancement I mean I could do the zone scan right now
There's another blue backpack.
I'll do the zone scan.
If I get shot!
I swear to God!
Oh my, I'm on the high ground.
If I get shot!
There you go.
Oop.
Open an assault.
Did you do that?
Oh wait, I can do that?
Wait, wait, is that a new thing where if you scan a fucking
read-up code,
in wait is that thing wait what are you talking about what
happened arena ploy just spawned in in front of my scan no
then someone put that down that had to be you oh okay that's
not a thing oh my god that's so cool i mean that'd be cool
if that was the real thing batteries i have not found like
oh yeah that's called a power amp by the way so you get a
little power ramps kind of fire items heal over time or
should i get the over the the apparently it is the thing
ducky by the way oh it is oh it does wait how do you not
know you fucking play and cast this game yeah i'm here for a
ride dude come on man oh quick for a good time not a long
time bro no man um what you said reef 45 is goaded right
yeah re 45.
okay
i'm gonna go for this evo cash these little shits are here
again dude they're gonna be here they're waiting for you
they actually might be so we'll see what happens if i scream
and yell and cry don't worry i'm looking i'm looking for you
i'm kidding regardless though because i'm scared what do i
get for this do i want damage enemies to reduce ultimate
cooldown knock gives 50 alt charge access support bends
improve revive and death boxes have mrbs We want one.
Re45 R301.
I don't care.
Oh, you're him.
I love that out of you.
Wait, what do I get?
Do I get the ultimate conductor or help is here?
Which one's which?
I don't know the names of them.
Help is here is access support bins, improve revive, and
death boxes.
Ultimate conductors damage enemies to reduce ultimate
cooldowns and knock is 50% alt charge.
I mean, I would just go double left if I was you.
Double left, so help is here.
Yeah, I would say so.
For sure.
Someone's looking at me, a sniper.
Oh, back here.
They're here.
Everybody sniping them.
I'm looking.
I just cried the other one.
I cried too over there.
There's a sublet sign.
255 sublet, they're running away.
They're scared.
That's right.
Run!
They already ran.
They're gone.
That's right.
I don't even know why it's shooting out, smoked out.
Yeah, pussy out, boys.
Yeah, pussy use.
tell them yeah sit down that has to be monsoon dude he keeps
peaking us every time or something's going on i told you why
did you tell him they want they want the what's it called so
bad dude yeah but he's not even gonna get the kp that's the
thing no he doesn't want to kill us he wants the beacons i
know that oh he wants to rotate they don't have anything on
their side they're up here now 60.
don't even they're just showing up there we just keep moving
in okay welcome behind you down oh i got shot from the left
i got shot from my left but no way really we're getting gate
kept again i'm pretty sure we are someone floats on me yeah
this team's gonna fight us under me under me under you
what's happening i'm with i think you back yeah i need you
back wait this is crazy we're getting colluded on her now i
might die yeah this is this is weird bro why are we getting
yeah this is bad docker we're in come on man what's going on
dude yeah they might put us they might put us we'll see yeah
i'm putting i'm putting fences here i mean tatty the resort
bro bro what the fuck he has a cringe i live a little bit
guys the fuck are we doing yeah i'll look right out of the
windows where they're at i think they left dude what the
hell was fringe guys come on they're gone they're gone I
think I don't know if they're fully gone but we'll see when
I'm fucking walking out here because they're routing us
maybe just might be in like last time watch out watch out
with these fools man I'm moving up I'll cue if I need to all
right I'll let you scout up to the right so that's fine
right side teams aren't a problem there's a left side team
if they come we might be problem I'll move up the bridge
real quick so we're getting fucking sniped okay you get like
speed boost from it yeah Yeah.
They're just helping you out, dude.
Making you rotate faster.
Mad Maggie's insane.
I hate that guy.
I'm just waiting for this.
They're getting looking over.
I don't know where they're at.
They're just kind of like playing slow.
I don't even know where to put my defenses.
We're not even going to go here.
Yeah, we just keep moving on up, I think.
There's nothing to really fight or anything.
Just keep on moving.
Watch out for this team that was on the left.
I don't know where they're going to be at.
We'll see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't see them right now.
I want to hit these peeking.
I don't know where the fuck these guys are at.
they might be ratting this dude would not doubt it i had six
med kits if someone wants one oh what six med kits damn oh i
fat fingered that oh good no worries that's fine that's fine
great i'm lagging again by the way okay i think we go hit
this uh this this car oh i'm lagging i won't slide down oh
oh that's not good but that's fine oh the server's really
bad what is going on all the servers really bad lady our now
she's apex legends shout out my dogs all right let's try to
hit this console beacon if we can't see there's zones going
i put it i got rid of a 2x of anyone so actually i'll stand
around taking the 2x and getting rid of by two by four
servers are terrible man holy fuck uh-oh it's like the first
game all over again for me oh no someone sees okay but if
it's if i got a two by four not bad not bad i got infinite
shield batteries it is all right i swear if i can shot i'll
smoke you i'll smoke you yeah yeah thank you i did not
receive a smoke yeah yeah no if you're gonna shot it i got
okay okay okay all right where are we going oof not great
let's keep on moving let's keep it rotational we're good
that's fine 45 seconds i definitely don't want to fight
without bad my lag is right now it's okay yeah i'm pretty
sure what i would do that was just good yeah yeah you don't
have your roller too so that's also
That'd be better to be on MNK while I'm lagging.
I can't lie.
Oh, for sure.
It's so much better.
But wouldn't your aim assist kick in when you're lagging?
Maybe imagine it just slow.
It helps me out so much.
Oh my god.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Are you lagging too?
It's just me.
No, it's just you.
It's just you.
Dude, this is insane.
It's like one player per team.
I'm just...
That's crazy, bro.
I saw you float there.
One of my boys said he was lagging terribly too.
What the fuck is going on?
His server's dog shit.
yeah i'm getting 50 ping on these because i'm florida what
the what the i'm getting like 900 000 ping right now this is
crazy all right we're gonna move actually let's go right
let's stay right i'm just gonna put fences here be like
we're here yeah let him know yeah i'll be like they'll see
the fence like oh we shouldn't go this way there's a guy
exactly and i'm that guy
Be aware of our presence.
I can't believe how bad this is.
This is actually so sad.
Hey, look, a team died, though.
Yeah, huge for us.
Fuck them.
Yeah, fuck them.
Not lost.
Let's go.
W for us.
W?
Behind us, actually.
I can't even fucking look, man.
This is so ass.
Where?
I'm trying to look right now.
Behind us.
Someone behind us.
Yeah, they're going to off evac right there.
I think on yours, actually.
I'll just shoot them so they won't try and...
There's shots from here, too.
Yeah, there's another team behind him, 100%.
I'm going to look forward a little bit to see what's going
on.
We're good right now.
Team on front, Sue.
What?
I don't got the funds for this.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
If you want, I can put out the alts right now here.
Yeah, I mean, if you want to put it right here, not against
it.
Yeah.
Went down.
And then you don't have to charge.
Don't have to use your shields anymore.
Wow, she's smart.
She's gaming.
I said, oh, my God.
There's a team in front.
There's a team in front of me.
No, this is awful timing.
I'll help it.
Yeah, it's good ulti.
Good ulti, good ulti.
This is bad timing.
Yeah.
I'm liking so bad.
This is horrible timing.
It's fine.
Keep me going.
We're good.
I'm going to try to get my possession.
Try to get fences up if you can.
Oh, one hit.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Nice, nice.
Keep holding.
We're fine.
Stay inside of again.
We're good.
Push it up on board.
On door, on door.
Oh, dude, this is so ass.
Dude, they might push up.
They're pushing up.
100 percent percent percent oh i got hit i got hit through
that i'm just lagging man yeah no it's just unlucky that we
were lagging suckers bro why am i on 900k what is this
that's just unlucky bro i can't even like call to make
anything happen i'm just lagging everywhere yeah there's
nothing we could do if we're lagging super high i kept
throwing my smokes down and keep disappearing dude oh yeah
the watson alt does that you have to do it like for further
because the watson up does that oh geez louise i was like
dude i was like freaking out because my smokes weren't going
i was getting shot and i was like i ran away from your ult
and then i got into their los oh no yeah that's just unlucky
because they we wig was lagging so it was like a 2v3 right
oh saying you're saying that both of his teammates are on
like 9 000 ping right now Yeah, it's not fun.
Dude, that's so insane, man.
How is that even possible, brother?
Also, why can't I not see who killed me?
Oh, they're on streamer.
They're on anonymous mode.
So people can't, like, target other people.
It's just an apex thing.
No, I think Moxie's all went through.
I saw you get, like, hits on it.
30 so it definitely went through yeah it's just unlucky
because we was lagging so it became a 2v3
and then we were getting pincered too bro i got i got i'm
not gonna lie i ran in circles to get cracked both ways i
think i got i got fucking um 100 to zero instantly because i
think all three people shot at me i was like i couldn't even
like like react in time
That's, that has to be their pro player.
What the fuck?
No, their pro literally just hit like 800 damage.
Who did it?
Uh, the pro player.
They did like, they hit like 800 damage on that one team.
Okay, which one do they shoot in hell?
Okay, which one?
They're Mad Maggie.
Oh, Mad Maggie?
Yeah.
Yeah, but he's getting all their kills and they're not
getting the KP.
Yeah, fucking pussies.
Yeah, he's CTG Zuri.
CTZ Zuri.
Is that Citadel?
That's Citadel, right?
I know that from Rivals.
Yeah.
That's the only reason why I know that.
Guess 2k damage.
Sheesh.
Maybe it's time for you to pull up Pathfinder.
No, actually, that's what I'm thinking.
Yeah, yeah, you sat up full of the patsy.
I might.
Would be funny if Pathfinder gets banned here.
There's no way.
There's nobody's playing Pathfinder.
Oh, that's the worst part.
Because it's going to take fucking forever for this game to
end.
That's the worst part about Apex Competitive.
Dude, by far the worst part.
You just sit there and you have to just eat it.
It's terrible.
hate fucking awful i i that's why like i never do watch
parties of apex competitive because i just don't want to
wait till at the end zone and this is just like like like 70
of just waiting you're just waiting for teams rotating and
everything and i'm just like like waiting but yeah no the
end game fights are cool but it's like it takes so long for
me to get there no 100 i got it the exact
Yeah, I hate slow burn.
Fuck that shit.
Just want gas gas gas.
Bro, I feel like this like this ability that goes through
walls and burns is so like Mad Maggie?
Mad Maggie?
She's really good in turn situations, honestly.
I mean, do you want to try Mad Maggie, Moxie?
Oh hell nah.
But when I play something new for the first time, it's bad.
nice wiggle so analyze that situation besides you know
besides your lag like uh what should we have done or we were
we just cooked like no no we could like that for sure no so
what would happen if i wasn't lagging i would have swung out
i got angles on that like stairway to make them not push or
at least help our situation but i just couldn't swing out
and help you guys so they just were able to take so much
space because i just had to sit behind that counter and just
not die so the drill it's like pretty unfortunate because
the drill the way they placed it was burning us behind the
counter if i'm going to push out a little bit and then cue
back in if i get damaged they don't really have that like
free push every single time yeah it's unfortunate is what it
is yeah so it was just it was just was a 2v3 yeah i mean you
guys said your best but that's a really hard situation but
i'm watching this maggie this guy is this guy is clean yeah
that's the the probe there that's zuni man he's so why can't
the other team's pros lag i don't understand understand yeah
why is it just me man the worst problem why is it our pro
player that's lagging and then other pros are okay that's
what i'm saying bro make the worst fucking bro player in the
lobby lag is ridiculous exactly why nerf us we just hear the
vibe these katanas are sick though oh yeah no i like the i
always like somebody knows her fire i get like i mean you
literally have a fucking final fantasy story and i saw you
carrying that no this this tournament's rigged it is dude
they're blind on us old and bad's a good name what the fuck
that guy just do but i'm not gonna lie i thought that guy
threw that thing through the portal that'd be cool i don't
think it works like that though wait can you do this too wow
what i'm mad maggie wait yeah can you play like this no not
not mad maggie but can you play like this yeah 4k
I gotta let you guys take 4k damage, but I don't know.
I'm a digit out.
We're being targeted.
To seaweed, thai, siwi.
Maybe like, they like knew exactly, like, basically nerf,
they knew where you were, you were gonna play at the 100
thieves facility and, like, targeted big docs, they're like,
DDoSing your facility right now.
I wish.
Dude, my goal is to get more damage than nice wig combined.
That's so fucked.
That's fucked.
By the Tony Romo of Apex?
I think it's possible.
Never want anything, dude.
Just commentate now, bro.
That's how it goes.
I think it's possible only because you're lagging.
I don't think you can shoot a gun right now in your
situation.
Yeah, then we can't.
I think if you are lagging, I think if you are lagging, you
should just like tell, like, Yeah, just be it.
Can you restart lobby?
Yeah, I said that to you saying was lagging.
Ruby was lagging.
But then Golden Tots was lagging.
So we had like four people saying they were just doing
exactly what happened to me.
It was like you DC through the game.
They should.
I think that one was central and game two was East Coast.
Oh, OK.
So I don't know why.
They dissent our US East gives me 40 MS right now.
That's almost ending right now.
Yeah, I don't know.
Oh, I can finally watch a different team.
Yay.
Oh, I think someone else was...
I think someone else on the other team was lagging because,
like, they instantly left the server.
Alright, who's their bro?
I assume this is their bro.
Just looking at badges.
You could...
If you, like, spectate the teammates, you could see their
names, like, on top of their head.
who's the pro player so i just spectate the pro
wait when's the last time you played rivals um oh i don't
know not too long ago but probably i was playing it the
game's good as fuck dude i love that game i also love
watching it yeah it's just just i mean i didn't know apex
has been feeling like quite casual for me how has rivals
been i haven't touched it in a good amount of time though
like probably a month sucks but i feel like every hero
shooter just has horrible meta after horrible meta yeah no
the meta sucks right now because it's like oh my god look at
all the caught why are we playing cost oh i bet they're
gonna ban caustic now they got a bad cost they should have
banned them game one fuck that guy yeah i was surprised that
all two got banned and not caustic because i felt like a lot
of teams were running caustic there that's what i'm saying
why wouldn't we running caustic I don't know, man.
I thought we were going Pathfinder.
But like before.
I don't know.
It took so long for us to fucking figure out how to come.
You know what I mean?
Throwing in something else, a curveball would have been my
fucking loose fucking brain out.
Let me see.
I'm going to go roll over this game.
See what this feels like.
Let's do it.
See how give you what vibes you're feeling.
Yeah.
I just want to peep the vibes real quick.
But I feel like.
I don't know, man.
I feel like I'm low-key clueless.
It's okay.
On the fourth game, the fourth game, you're going to figure
it out.
You're not clueless, dude.
Why are you clueless?
Like, should I be going, like, I feel like maybe I should
just go life, like, boom, hit a little heel.
No.
I mean, it's up to you.
I think you go lifeline, bro.
I think you're itching for it.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, there's a...
Okay, what are you going to play?
There's a 10-minute break in between.
I'll play whatever you think.
How about that one, man?
How about that, dude?
I'm freaking out.
I don't even know half these characters.
All right.
How about we all do get in a party right now?
Who are?
Yeah, because there's a 10-minute break.
Okay.
All right.
It's an invite.
Invite.
All right.
Moxie, you invite me, and I'll invite Wig.
Okay.
Invited.
All right.
And then I'll invite Wig.
Where is Wig?
Oh, my God, dude.
We're back to Rower.
oh my goodness this feels crazy have you on do i oh i don't
have you on this account because we're always doing
tournaments and stuff so you know like recent players yeah i
don't have wait do you have him on recent no weak doesn't
with us like that oh whoa whoa i'll play games no more you
guys know this come on oh we got us oh okay what what do you
do with that i'm in the fire rolling in the hands one at us
i got you one second here why just cook real fast all right
we're cooking i'm about to be locked in for this one a lot
of nice weeks in here i might i don't know if i'll add that
we're so down there's a nice week dot underscore ttv is that
a hundred t space nice week that's gotta be me nice week yep
oh i got you i mean you're not the
too long dude not a stray away i respect the ground that
where are you at friend request i accepted you there you are
all right there you go well i'm higher level than you dokey
are you yeah and you're you're 153 i'm 307 i'm way worse
than you what the fuck i don't put always yeah because i i
didn't play on this account a long time guys guys you guys
said i don't know what i'm queuing up what am i queuing up
where are we playing are we playing wait Do wild Like every
other team plays, is playing a real comp, and then like, I
don't know what the fuck we're doing.
We're fucking doing it.
That's what we're doing.
Dude, am I faking it right now?
I thought I was drunk last night.
I'm still drunk now.
I think, like, I think how every other team plays, are
playing a real comp and then, like, I don't know what the
fuck we're doing.
We're fucking doing it.
That's what we're doing.
Guys, what's wrong with our comp, dude?
I don't even know.
You know what, I'm seeing no wraiths.
Yeah, I'm seeing no wraiths, Wig.
Why are you on wraiths?
I just played.
Okay.
Yeah, I saw, what do you mean?
Our last two games, you were on wraiths.
I'm a locktane for us.
So, like, wait, are you sabotaging our team with these cops?
No, the lag was, don't you?
I was on nine million per day.
Every 30 seconds, it took me out of the game and back in.
Yeah, but why is no one else playing Raid?
They're playing Costic.
They're playing Maggie.
Yeah, Costic, Maggie.
I play Maggie.
I can play Maggie next game.
All right.
Deal.
Come here.
I love you.
I love my nice little Mad Maggie gameplay.
That's cool, man.
I am on roller though.
I don't know how this is gonna go dude.
I'm kind of excited When was the last time you've been on
roller?
Ooh, seven months ago.
Oh, what?
Yeah, I don't play anymore.
Wait, what?
Seven months?
That's crazy.
I didn't think you were honest man.
You are.
What the fuck happened to you?
I don't know Much changed man, dude.
Bro, this is my map.
Like put me on Skulltown.
It's over.
I hate to break it too, but there's no skull town here.
Yeah, GD.
Just gun run?
Just gun run, dude.
That's it.
Oh, that guy was one, but...
This was my map.
How does...
Oh, I was gonna say.
Bro, this guy already has six kills.
Or like, at level six.
I'm coming over.
Probably cheating his ass off.
Honestly, I won't be surprised.
Well, scamming ass cheater didn't always.
I had cheaters in my gun game.
I can't be bad.
It's just if I die, it's a hacker.
Oh, sneeze.
Oh, God.
Bless ya.
Thank you guys so much.
Yeah, I'm a good person.
Shit on bad, buddy.
Let him know, let him know.
Shoot his body a little bit too.
He's probably a 14-year-old.
That's right.
Log off.
yeah go to fucking school nerd yeah exactly Sunday go to
school yeah go to church bro what you out here for the apex
where I know I'm not going to heaven what about you you have
no excuse me what are you doing on this door man can we dude
get a job dude how about i die to you like that bro get a
job sit down make sure we look out for the announcement too
when we're playing sure yeah sure we're in a tournament bro
it feels so weird to play go back and praise jesus bro is
there some mmar in this game i don't feel like these guys
are killing me too good for sure there is yeah there's gotta
be it's gotta be my oh my god okay i was gonna say wait if
you died to that guy i swear to god hey what are you doing a
bunch of me bro what the yeah use that aim assist dude get
them out of you get them out of you that was actually crazy
this is just so strong i feel like oh my god i feel so slow
now it's yeah but the aim assist is so strong though though
it there's be so fun for me though i'm putting so what's
this guy doing it's kind of molly water this one's still me
bro does everyone know how to do like these fancy movements
yes at this point yes oh wow oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah what
the fuck wait you let that happen to me what did it happen
to you wait a minute oh caustic that makes the next that
makes the drone Yeah, yeah, yeah, no problem, bro.
Great, great team player.
This is why I hate Lifeline.
I hate being a team player.
Yeah, I know you do.
It's about your honor, to be honest.
So what separates like the best player and like a good one?
Um, I mean, it really just depends, dude.
You know, like- Depends on what?
I don't know.
Mechanics could be like a really good player on like one
character, you know?
is the main thing aim and then probably after that ability
usage and then movement after that but aim number one which
is why controller is so good on this goddamn game there you
oh no long bow whoa don't should talk oh my god not the long
bow bumbo's dirty yeah but i haven't shot the longbow in 20
that guy is i hit this I'm a single that's cool.
I haven't fucking shot a limbo.
It's so annoying.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Well, never mind.
I'm on knife.
I'm on knife!
Whatever you don't even...
No!
One
of us got hit!
Who has knives?
I'm on me, me, me, me.
Get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it.
way to god single p20 is stupid as here you go here's a no
where was he no way oh god oh god i can't i can't control
the knife hit the knife hit it i'm trying we can't lose a
gun run guys we cannot lose a gun run why can't you hit the
dive i'm on p20 why are you on p20 I actually don't know I
more kills you on all this works.
I have I swear I've killed two people have 19 some points I
did I did I did I did I we don't do it.
We're free.
We don't fucking lose that.
Oh my gosh Wait, there's throwing knives.
Yeah, no, it's the match.
Shut up Oh my god, yeah, welcome back.
I can't wait to leave again dude It's sheesh that would be
under this is a humbling experience are they have they
started they haven't yet oh wait no they have lobby code
lobby code is out rape is bad what the you are the only one
playing rape in this lobby I like that keep a band keep a
band who cares who's not banning some characters dude I
don't know why they're not ban it cost needs to be banned
literally game one i understand i don't understand why
didn't they ban range guys guys we are we're talking about
the bands why don't we play caustic you want me hop on it
i'm down you want to fuck it run caustic yeah just got in
someone's random fire range lobby how did you who is this
who is this guy i'm on how i'm on caustic i just realized
they target band two characters from you wig yeah what the
fuck is going on what i'm literally lagging yeah yeah
banning wigs characters dedossing rigged dude what is that
bullshit man why am i getting a hold out of her how many
people are in that lobby a lot or no no it's like only 40
i'm gonna pee all right back too i'm gonna keep one up
why do i feel like this costicle it's not that big so good
though it's like insane how good it is
why does it keep making me all right let me yeah i'm running
caustic fuck it fuck it do it dude i believe in you
i'm back so what comp are you playing i think he wants to
play caustic dude yes why are you you're talking about me
like like i'm a uncontrollable beast Okay, I want you to be
man.
I want you to be to play caustic He whatever he you know, I
guys I'm able to be talking to you know I'm just feeling
like we're complaining about caustic.
I feel like we should have a caustic.
I'm willing to be that guy I want you man.
I want you to be an untameable legend.
I believe in you.
That's what I'm saying Yeah, it just feels like I'm like a I
don't know Like a zoo animal, you know Yeah, yeah, and we're
unlocking the gate now.
No, he's not a good thing.
yeah because we're scared we're scared yeah exactly like we
can't control him like he's gonna go caustic i'm here for
the team here all right oh yeah bro yeah i'm all ears i
think i'm all ears i think he played caustic dude yeah all
right then i'm on caustic that's it man yeah so i'm caustic
you're mad maggie doki what are you going i don't know sure
when am i going That's up to you.
What do you want to play?
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Wait, but what goes best with Kostik?
Ash, bingo, Lord.
I mean, you're a good bang, right?
You're a good bang.
Okay, I'm going bing.
Yeah, you're a good bang, you know?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
No confidence in yourself.
No, yeah.
Yeah.
We just start having confidence here, guys.
Well, I didn't mean to tell you to play Mad Maggie.
It just seems like you want to go with that.
I'm not for Maggie.
I think Doki wants to be with anyone else.
Okay, wait.
You also have Pathfinder?
Okay, so, okay, now I'm confused, guys.
Now I'm getting confused.
What is...
About what part are you confused about?
Like, what is our comp?
So, like, caustic, Mad Maggie, and then whatever you want.
Whatever I want, that's too much free will.
I don't like that.
Okay, well, if you want me to decide for you, then we run
the...
Oh, well, run a little...
run a little a little um okay never mind and caustic perfect
i love that at us actually kind of like that we should have
played caustic for the first three games we trolled what do
you mean we what are you wait you're the igl and you fucking
told us not to play caustic where's the we come from guys
how do we troll yeah any translators this guy speaking
french i don't know what he's talking about that blaze on
moxie and i we need some type of movement okay so now we
gotta figure out what moxie and i should play bang bang for
moxie unless he wants to play watson or lifeline or path
okay okay so i think you play path i think you play path
okay and then who's the third that's a good question so in
these situations if i'm playing maggie we'd probably like
something Or Watson.
Which is better?
I'm good on adding.
Okay.
I would say, hmm.
Ah, it's a tough one.
It's tough.
I'm going to say Watson for sure is better.
I got this.
Watson, Tad.
Are you guys in the zone in the in the custom game?
Yeah, not only me.
I'm coming.
By the way, there's three people missing and two of them are
on my team.
Okay.
What's the code?
That's the code?
Where's the code hiding?
Okay.
It is on the Battle 5, by the way, guys.
But it's okay.
I've looked once.
I'm depending on you for that one thing there.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
No, I may have been spamming the same code you linked me for
40 minutes ago.
So.
Yeah, I got you guys the code.
It's okay.
We're not the last people in.
Thank God.
Okay.
We're good.
We got the wall now.
So you can, I guess you go downstairs.
Wait.
This map, this map is getting hard.
It's a tough map.
but it's gonna be a little bit more difficult for us for
sure oh my god it's even harder i think this map i think
this map is harder yeah i would say and i'm also on roller
now so it might be a little more difficult we're gonna see
what's going on wait but what about your aim assist yeah i
don't really don't matter but it's seven months dude yeah
but it's like riding a bicycle yeah you ride like riding a
bike yeah it's like riding a bike the controller takes over
oh i'm really rocking up now i say all right wall you guys
laid up top i go down down below okay wait but what
character right oh i'm playing watson i figured it out and
i'm on pathfinder really dude you just shed 90 times i was
saying caustic i was so underneath this impression i was
playing caustic yeah he's bad bro i know he needs you
brother they found out that we were filing up like caustic
and then they added a fifth bad that's crazy i did not want
publishing bro so i think you go i think you go path man
yeah i think you go path all right all right what do you
think everyone else is playing i'm gonna be real right now i
don't know what everyone's gonna be playing in this
situation there's a lot of bands i think it might be comfort
picks like whatever you think is the best for you type of
style of gameplay coming out here soon okay okay yep so i
would say you know we follow that maybe a little bit let me
crazy if they Oh, no, Brad.
I actually love that brush.
Every character we want to play, they just bat us.
I really hope that happens.
I'm legit going to be first-time, Inc.
All right.
Pathfinder, and you're going Watson?
Yeah.
I'm Watson.
Okay.
I'm going to be Watson, and I'm going to be Mad Maggie.
Oh, man, guys.
I'm very greedy, guys.
I'm a very selfish player when I play Pathfinder.
I got to start thinking, like, for the team.
I mean, I saw...
I can't lie.
Good, man.
Be a little selfish.
Yeah, be selfish.
I'm not going to lie, that one game where I downed someone,
my Loki was running in the zone thing and you guys were dead
and you guys were both full because I was low.
So.
Oh, so that's how you sacrifice for yourself.
That's good.
Oh, no, that was after.
You need that.
Now, you need that in Apex Legends.
You really have to be selfish.
Yeah, I want to be like a rat.
I want to really just rat and run.
Well, maybe we can do the strat.
after we die, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or we could do the strat where, like, we all go our separate
ways and start riding in three separate corners.
Well, I was just, like, scared of...
You guys dying, because these guys, like, kind of beamed me,
so I was like, oh, shit, they're good.
But you thought that we had no chance.
Yeah, yeah, at least they're better than me.
So...
So that means you think you're better than both of us, yeah.
Yeah.
Understood, yeah.
I believe.
And a 2v3.
Tasha.
Yeah.
Okay I'm so confident going into this game guys.
This is really gonna be the one right now This is it.
We're so warmed up now guys.
This is it.
I understand.
The fourth game is where we lock it in.
Where's Watson?
Oh boy.
Oh, there she I was the first game is where we lock it in
guys.
I had to see if you were gonna get it.
I wasn't even gonna tell you At that point made the fuck it
like you know, I mean nice little default pathfinder love
that out of us We're dialed I don't even know if...
Yeah, I have no skins.
Here's the comeback.
I believe in the comeback, guys.
Look at that.
Look at the kills, though.
Oh, oh, 7,000.
Yeah, wait a minute.
You're an experienced Apex-ledding gamer.
Wait, did I just saw 0, 0, 0 from your Mad Maggie?
Yeah.
It wasn't like...
It was all like season 0, like season, like whatever kills.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I played a lot of Mad Maggie my time.
Don't worry.
All right, that's good to know.
That's good to know.
We're on control though.
Never on control.
I got a little worried there.
I haven't played Roller in seven months, and I've never
played Matt Maggie on Roller.
It's okay.
Our name is WashG.
They know what they were getting.
Definitely know what they're going to get with this one for
sure.
I did not go down below, by the way, because I was scared
for a second, so.
Oh.
I don't even know what down below means.
Um, are you going to go down below?
We'll go there.
We'll go there together.
We'll navigate.
Down below.
round one down below all right got our nine i got my guns
i'm lagging again i'm gonna maul do oh wait i'm lagging
terribly again oh yeah this is insane i'm lagging a little
too now yeah i'm getting i'm getting i'm gonna call for
reset reset i feel so bad for a niyamoko dude this is awful
to deal with you're hosting a tournament no worse why is it
today too i'm gonna be real after we went to like the amazon
servers the private match servers are just absolutely
terrible oh have they always been that bad when you were
when we watch fighting or this one's particularly bad they
they play on like high prio servers for their tournaments oh
and scrambles but it's bad i think these ones it's bad of
the servers so yes we're kind of up they're not even like
really good ones in this feel bad should we go to respawn
beacon should i grab that or should i go i would rescue i
got our evac tower i would i would take them away i'd take
them up okay oh god that was not a bad call you guys want to
go inside and grab some stuff real quick or now yeah we
definitely go there yeah 100 i'm with you you said no one
was down there right no one should landing that they someone
that have a spot here and here okay i'm lagging so bad bro
this is just abysmal give me one game without lag i'm
literally begging dude that's unlucky i'm going to to put
like fences on this just hope that nobody jumps in so re45
is the best um not best but not
bad don't be so stressed man it's all good just say a s or b
tier man like something okay hey i already put it by man but
it's also not give him a tier list bro he needs a tier bro
He needs a tier list.
Yeah, like this guy, he says, oh, it's good, but it's not
the best, but it's also okay.
It's all right.
I have a 3x or 2x if anyone wants one.
Oh, I need that.
I need that 2x.
You want 2 or 3?
Oh, I can only put a 2.
Okay, I'll give you a 2.
Wait, access to ring consoles?
Well, I have ring console already, so you don't need it.
Yeah, you don't need that.
You should get the survey.
This is insane.
This is bad.
I'm lagging too.
Look at this.
Woo.
No, I can't even climb up this.
No, this is terrible.
This is actually ridiculous.
I'm like.
Wee.
The zone is going to end in cascade balls, so right
underneath cascade it's going.
I mean, we could just set up now.
Oh, my God.
This lag is crazy.
Anyone have an evac tower?
No, right?
Nope.
No, I grabbed the respawn.
i double check nobody loaded this area yet this is insane oh
my i can enhance my r45 we oh my god the slowest jump down
of my life i'm gonna get jeaned with the slow mode i think
it's so cringe that the pro players get the proud server but
no one else does it's like what wait wait someone just
sparrow did about me yeah sparrow cute about me i know we're
here i don't know where that was though oh i i saw saw
something like up right yeah yeah i see him it's doesn't we
can't do anything yeah no i'm trying to get inside i think
they're lagging too oh my god there oh okay really okay
that's they're oh bro they're lagging so bad too that's
hilarious dude that's why they sparrow keyed we should get
some kills here then i think we're lagging just as well as
them yeah we're just we're lacking as well so i don't know i
got no i got no long range but i got a re and a r99 oh my
god this is i don't know what you're sniping i don't know
how you're gonna be sniping right now i just hit him it's
actually so he's hit him twice wait really oh my that was
like cheese i already keep it moving let's keep going to
cascade i'm coming over to you it just takes me a while but
no do you think i wonder what the no reg's gonna be like
Horrible for sure.
We're without it out It's a really bad no regs up.
Oh, oh, I'm just surprised we didn't get a game reset with
how bad this lag is Did no one?
Oh, no We're to keep going this way down below Dude, this is
so bad.
Yeah, I don't want to jump because I'm worried that they'll
just fucking beat me off I can't slide down the mountain.
I just run Beat me off.
They need to beat me off first All right, chat bottom man
all right i got an evac tower we're going to use this later
thank god all right well we'll be there in about 38 minutes
but if we get there we're going to look real real good guys
i promise yay we're going to make it i'm right behind you
wig right behind i don't understand how people are getting
kills right now if anyone got a white mag i need it oh look
out kid i'll look out but I don't know why I just like lied
to my voice it's like traveling to your PC now dude the lags
in your PC just the cheese touch we're gonna keep on moving
in by the way try to get over there but try is the is the
word here yeah I mean if we die on this this would suck lag
is literally them will die you I'm all right.
I can't move, dude.
I've got the package here.
You have a zip line, Moxie, by chance.
Yep, I got a zip.
Can you zip to this nut sack building over here?
Reach.
Suck.
Boom.
Let's go.
I'm going to put a queue down just in case.
No one's in there.
We're going to go.
We should be good.
I don't think anyone's in there.
Are we living in that house?
We're not going to try to move a little bit deeper, but I'm
nervous to land on lagging.
I'm so nervous.
Well, I think we're good now.
We're good.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm good now.
Yeah, we're kind of good actually.
Yeah, yeah, I'm healthy.
I'm chilling.
I'm doing not bad.
Well, you know, players, players, players to East.
East, okay.
I'm playing.
You're gonna shot at.
Right here.
There's a player.
There's shots here, too.
Yep, yep.
Should we just stay here for now?
Oh, we're lagging again?
Okay.
I'm up.
Yep.
I felt that.
It's just gonna come and go.
That's all it is.
I got no long range guns.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Looking behind us.
So where are we moving to?
We're going to go over here late game.
Okay.
Like an evac tower or something.
But for right now we definitely don't want to land over
there because we had a bunch of people.
Yeah, two over here.
I see it.
I'm just going to let them know.
I can't even pay, bro.
I'm here.
Get out.
Just letting them know that we're here, you know?
Oh, there's people here too.
Yeah, it's fine.
Hit one somehow.
No damage.
Yep.
This is nutty.
I see a charge rifle to our right.
Did you see that?
I did see that.
There's a charge rifle in this direction.
Try to see if there's anywhere for us to land later.
Watson fences over there.
Watson fences there.
We're good, though.
Mm-hmm.
Feel that.
Check, check, check.
We're good.
Check, check.
Play slow.
We're good to go.
And more teams die.
Let the lag come out.
And then we're good to go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let them die by the lag.
Someone needs it.
Yeah.
I'm good.
I'm chilling, man.
Yeah.
Oh, you need it?
Oh.
No, we're good.
We're good.
They're moving up.
Blue armor?
Looking?
Yep, yep.
They're just trying to smoke me, but you'll miss.
They hit me.
I'll get up.
Did it hit me?
They hit me now?
You taking one?
Okay.
You don't want to kill me?
Really?
All right.
I'll put an alt right here then.
Yeah, maybe just put one down.
We're just going to try to hold this building as much as
possible.
I'll put it here.
These guys are going to push us.
Are they actually pushing?
I don't think so.
They're rotating.
They rotate it to the left.
Okay.
We want them gone.
Got some damage on the board.
Nice.
Good damage on the board, man.
I love that damage on the board 15 yep all right they're
moving left let them keep going honestly yeah yeah fucking
wait top 15 let's go let's go let's go the lag is on our
side I know a little bit actually yeah yeah because we found
the house we found a place to live thriving we're thriving
we're thriving see look at that I we did some shots there
and they fucked off beautiful where to get some fucking shot
shot I think it's that 15 damage right there I think so too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're a fucking genius, my guy.
There's 15 damage.
You're like, oh god, we cannot be there.
They're fighting up there too, man.
Good.
Fuck him.
See ya.
I'm gonna get some more recon.
You guys stay here real quick.
One second.
Yeah, see ya.
I wanna be ya.
Oh yeah, I'm L-starring this range.
You're gonna L-star.
Yeah, you hit those.
You hit those for sure.
Ain't no fucking doubt about it, man.
Don't forget who you are.
I'm re-45, I think.
real shit oh fucking shit
check our ride yep yep oh my god
whoa moxie you wild yep whoa whoa actually damn bro hit it
hey look at that you see that you're gonna hurt you see that
tank like that's kind of gross Yeah, it is Duck Hunt tab.
Duck Hunt is crazy.
I want to see where Zone goes.
It's pulling away, so that was expected.
It's pulling to us.
No, it's gonna be pretty far.
Yeah, I mean, we're definitely in the right spot.
I just don't know where we can land safely right now.
It's like my next concern.
I don't know if these buildings are taken.
We don't have a character that can really tell us that.
So we might have to eat back.
Yeah, there's someone here.
Someone there.
Yeah, on the left one.
Yeah, a big one, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Is there someone in this small one?
You see this?
I don't know.
I can't really tell.
Put a drill down and maybe get some recoil.
There's someone right here.
Okay.
We're gonna put a nearby down.
We're at the fly late game, okay?
Like last second.
We're going to...
Our goal?
Our goal is to go to this, by the way.
Right here.
I might have notified a team that we're back.
Oh, wait, that guy has a car.
Someone's got a car.
Yeah, they got a car and drone.
What the?
Fuck?
They repositioned here.
No, they took our spot.
we want to go to fuck that sucks actually yeah yeah well
they what way they left the other building they left this
build i think it's because someone was in that maybe like
there was a team in that building and then they went here
but they took the car there i don't know the big one the
small building you know i don't know i just saw like the guy
came from here and then he rotated here okay here economy
we're got the evac in let's just do it we're literally gonna
die maybe but we'll see we'll see just follow me on my
flight we'll see what happens we have no way to know if ones
in these buildings but fuck it let's just try it we have
literally no recon at all we're gonna land in this building
they left from so wherever they left we're going to that
building if we could reach it oh keep on flying just hold
height hold strong hold height oh shit we should be good we
should be good we should be good we're fine honest i don't
know we got the routing yet come in come in come in come in
come in we're good i'm taking them get up first floor it's
for first stay here stay here come outside come to my side
come to my side we're good Yeah, we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Nice, nice, nice.
Get up.
Ha ha.
You little bitches, bro.
Trying to rat our shit, huh?
Oh, wait.
No.
Mother suck us.
Are you serious?
Our rotation was so good.
That was our best run.
Are you serious?
Bro, we just went crazy on it.
Bro, we survived.
I just, dude.
As they knew.
They knew they were like, they rolled the numbers and they
saw us at the end.
So they were like, we gotta end it.
We just cooked so fucking hard, man.
They saw us at the end.
And they, they, they saw my damage on the board.
They were saying, well, he's cooking too hard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel so bad for Nia, man.
She's definitely stressed.
Oh, I feel bad.
But everyone's complaining about the lag last game, too.
couple last three games yeah it's just tough dude i don't
know what they could do postpone the tournament and then
demand cryo how did they not get cryo anyways i don't know
how do you not how is like no one from the apex scene like a
dev that should be operating this like helping them out with
coach this is great because it's an official creator
tournament too it is i mean they have like help from V&M
who's like running Scrims before, but this is so bad.
I feel so bad for her.
It's not like anyone, it's not her fault, obviously, but
it's like so insane.
Wild.
Someone give her fucking prio codes, man.
Someone that knows fucking Scrim codes, give her one.
That's Scrims also.
Scrims haven't been laggy, though, right?
Like...
No, they've been better, but like really like, yeah, I mean,
even better for sure.
100%.
But they're still just lag here and there no matter what.
But I'm not this bad.
This is like pretty fucking terrible.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, a lot of teams died so early.
It's okay.
As long as we're having a good time together as a team.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I'm talking about, man.
We are having a great time together.
Teamwork.
Exactly.
I decided to not go to the dentist today I wanted to play
with you guys my gums are swollen
they had an emergency dentist appointment and they're like
it starts at 12 and i was like oh my tournament starts at 12
you know what my teammates are more important see that's why
you're the goat teammate yeah see i prio my team
inspirational my chat is not happy
it's okay guys i have an appointment tomorrow i got pushed
up a day i hope we're in your code i don't know do we have a
new code oh we do i do i don't know if this is the new code
or the old code no it's a new code new code that checks out
yeah yeah team were temporary teammates are forever guys you
know the vibes Mm-hmm.
Fuck me, man.
I don't even know where you find these codes.
There's so many channels in this.
Like, you'd think it'd be an announcement or something.
It's healer.
I have to go to battle five for it.
Oh, the website.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The website usually has them, but I don't even look at that
shit either, man.
I fucking hate that website.
I have a fucking vendetta against that thing when I
competed, man.
I think fucked me over so many times.
Fuck that shit.
I believe in this.
froze and there was a phase out on me so that's that must
suck apparently someone the reason said she restarted in the
first place because a whole team froze and they got killed
immediately oh really oh that sucks it does suck
guys i bet you in the new game in this new lobby that we're
getting the end zone will be like on the other side of the
map i feel it
Why are you wishing that on us, dude?
I'm going to watch this as a diary.
What if I'm reverse jinxing it?
And then, like, the game was, like, I'm going to prove her
wrong.
And then they reverse jinx it.
That could happen.
All right.
We'll see what happens here.
I mean, I'm hope.
Well, how about you literally just, you know, manifest?
No, if I manifest, it never goes well.
That's if I, that's too much hope.
There you go.
fucking terrible every time i don't want it yeah yeah yeah
because then it'd be a nice surprise you know yeah this
every time i try to do good things for myself it just always
goes the opposite way exactly unfortunately it's called the
monkey paul exactly me fuck me i get that too much you ran
away fear damn we should talking
where we missed oh we're missing a lot of people so many
people are on bathroom breaks yeah gotta take their pp break
i'm mad at him for it
what is monster that's why they're always that's why they're
always gatekeeping us he has a he has a man crush on you bro
oh i'm about six years of that now how it goes why are you
why are you leading him on that's up forbidden love dude he
has him up so so or so you're the one leading him on how do
you move don't you you're the one leading him on when he has
a fiance yeah you shouldn't tease people with the fiance
yeah you shouldn't tease if he's teasing me yeah he has one
yeah but you're you're giving it you're you're you're he's
dishing it and you're receiving it you're not you're not
getting it you're not I don't like the attention.
Restraining order.
Yeah, but that attention is kind of nice.
Oh, you're a home wrecker.
Look at this one real quick.
Yeah.
Let him come over here real quick.
Here, invite him over to the facility.
Come through.
Enough room in this fucking place, man.
Fucking ran 38 miles for controller.
Alter causing Valkyrie.
Okay, G7, a happy triple take.
That was what we did last time, right?
Same shit?
Yeah.
That's literally the same shit we have to play.
They can't remove guns?
No.
We just can't pick it up.
They're like private match settings are absolutely terrible.
That's like one other thing that Apex just is awful with.
Can't really do any customization at all in a private match.
Yeah.
Pretty ass.
Maybe in the future.
dip that shit in the soy sauce in your belly button is it
talking about you yeah yeah he wants to eat sushi off my
body oh shit i see and it's me i'm the issue here yeah but
you're encouraged he didn't tell him to stop i mean yeah i
won't you're right i definitely love that man you just love
that attention from taking men it's my dog only my homies
though oh so multiple taken men yeah only the homies though
only homies damn you got a collection down to ban charge
rifle there's badass names here decumite sick names dude and
i'm just fucking nice wig who's yeah who's uh like picking
the bands it's like a random dice i think it's just the
gotcha depending on like what because like He banned fucking
rape and only wig was playing rape.
So I was like, yeah, I don't know what the fuck like you
literally It's like the Marvel rivals bad system you hit the
30% Tell moxie what weapons to use this guy is paralyzed by
weapon choices Okay, okay, we should have given him a tier
list Make a tier list right now Dominic like apex content.
Where's the nice wig tier list of guns?
Yeah Right now, okay, here's a little tier list.
Don't pick up fucking...
It's not tier list.
The goddamn RE45 again, dude.
Just take the R9.
And the Volt.
You mean the RE45?
RE, sure, yeah.
That's the same thing.
What the... That's the same thing!
Oh, okay.
Oh, my bad.
Damn it, man.
God damn.
Yeah.
the Watson in all right we're good y'all we're gonna be good
we're fine what if we're one game we all played inverted
controls yeah that sounds horrible all right oh yeah thanks
my bad good fun so what are you eating right now dude
there's not only a fruit roll up to me chicken oh no Oh, all
right, so you're going downstairs now?
Yep, I'm gonna go downstairs, dude.
My monitor.
We're off for the lead start right now.
Oh, my God, you like turned robot-y for a sec.
All my monitors just shut off, dude.
No way.
Go for a restart.
Just be like, restart, please.
I'm about to literally...
Oh, but it's okay.
The server's bad.
No, I'm back.
It's okay.
The server's bad.
Dude, the server's bad again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
I'm back.
Bro, we could have just played it out the last game.
There's no difference, huh?
It's kind of crazy.
It's a difference.
The server is so bad.
Such a shame, though, man.
Fuck.
Yeah, this is why I don't try to host anything cool Yeah,
then you just feel the pressure the whole time like it's
your fault and the worst Yeah Wait, so I have X band, right?
Yeah, yeah, I have X band Oh, shit
Oh, my God, oh, this is bad I'm like, I'm hit hard this time
This time they hit me hard The lag's hitting you this time
Yeah, no, it's hitting me hard Like, cause like That's how
I'm Taking it on me Wait, are you, it's not hitting you?
No, I'm good right now.
Okay, that's fine, that's fine.
We don't, we don't need me.
We don't need me.
We have Whig now on Amos'.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
No, I actually got off the roller.
Oh, wait, what?
Yeah, yeah, I'm not going to kill you.
We need you, we need you.
We need you on.
Oh, go get back, get your ass back on that roller right now.
I threw it, dude.
It's gone.
It left the arena.
There's no auto-play here.
Can someone grab that?
I got a Moby.
I might keep this Moby, honestly.
Okay, Moxie, grab the redeploy.
I'm going to do...
Ping, where?
It's over here.
It's in that.
Alright.
I got the shed.
Got the redeploy.
I'm definitely lying about it for sure.
Oh, hey, look at that.
It's on the other side of the map.
I'm actually going to take this.
Wait, are you going?
I'm just going to the map?
Oh, my God.
You fucking did it to us, dude.
I told you.
I told you!
That was going to happen.
you you're a sick did you loot out everything inside i did i
did yeah i'm gonna put wait come with me i'm gonna put
fences there yeah for what for us what you mean for what i
swear if i get shot i got an r99 a nemesis have you guys
seen a repeater because i need a repeater oh i'm so bad it's
actually so bad holy like i don't even think i could look
out that window
Alright.
I'm on the way.
I'm coming over.
Where are we going, Wig?
One sec.
I had the roasted chatter real quick, so we're just gonna
rotate over to Cascade side real quick.
Yeah, one sec.
I gotta put some other place.
Well, I wanna hear that though.
Yeah, why did you mute yourself?
I wanna hear this roast.
Let us hear.
I'm mute yourself now, Wig.
Guys, okay, I got lost in the sauce.
I forgot to go under or up top.
Wait, what?
Wait.
I went under like after you guys were leaving it.
Picking up your scrap.
Yeah, yeah.
Picking up our trash.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad for me.
The lag is actually so unbearable.
I have a read-a-play.
Wait, we have two read-a-plays.
You're still muted, so we don't know what you want to do.
us to do oh yeah that too oh oh my goodness whoa golly jolly
i don't know what wake want us to do oh listen oh my god uh
wake is so so roasting you know let's let's keep it going
here oh and i'm frozen What the donut ping I see it I see it
Oh my god, I saw that Moxie, we're rolling out, we're
rolling out Go to Cascade So what were you talking about?
Dude, I had nothing I had to address that, I just get shit
on For like playing tournaments for some reason And try to
help people, it just makes no sense So I had to let them
know real quick Wait, you got shit on for what?
What was the comment?
Basically he said that I'm doing these tournaments for cash
grabs which like i don't even understand that's true this
tournament like doesn't even have that big of a we're doing
this as for fun bro you know i've been getting this for
years man so i gotta say something real quick you ever
thought stop being greedy yeah yeah that's true yeah that's
true wing have you ever thought about that how much more do
you need you're gonna need to take out small fries oh my god
i'm doing it for the cash so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
getting paid he's the only one getting paid in our team i'm
here to win moxie money dude that's what i'm here to do bro
that'll be you and right now i'm failing at his job yeah i
was promised to carry what happened here where's my 300 that
was like nice wig on the team there's freebies oh wow oh
yeah i saw a scan thing wait there is a scam we're lagging i
don't know if i want to fight this while we're lagging maybe
down below right side we'll go this way
I wanted that $300, bro.
Facts.
You're going to order me some food with that.
Yeah, exactly.
Can enable my bad habits of ordering takeout.
Oh, oh, my God.
Don't worry.
I got it.
It's made me enter and leave the game, like mid-match,
mid-match.
Yeah, that was happening to me too.
That was happening to me.
That's the lag.
Oh, it's the lag.
Yeah, that's the lag talking.
Oh, respawn.
I already have two.
We have two read.
I rather we just have a read-a-play.
If you guys see a repeater, let me know.
But I've been trying to find one.
I feel like we get shot at while...
Yeah, I think this is packet loss.
My gun is naked.
We got a naked R9.
Really?
Okay.
I have so much coffee.
I'll get you dressed up in the second.
Yeah, yeah, dressed up is good.
Oh, God.
Oh, oh, fuck.
no one dead i don't understand this is hell i need to get
this ego cash man i do i risk we go yeah yeah yeah yeah risk
it risk it risk it risk it we need it on me on me on me why
did you risk it he's cracked oh my god bro i'm just lagging
too i can't i don't you run don't you run run run oh bill
bad oh well there's a full team guys full team okay well
this is i this sucks because i'm the one that's lagging too
there's zero I can't even move.
I can't even move.
This sucks.
I literally can't even move.
Oh my god.
Wait, so where do we complain about lag?
Maybe we can get this game restarted.
Oh, brother.
Not a restart to that, man.
Our entire team died because of lag.
Literally up pausing.
Give me another restart.
Run it up, man.
Pausing every foot.
Give it another restart, dude.
That's such a shame, man.
Posing non-stop.
Oh, man.
That was just so sad.
That sucks.
I mean, yeah, I just went into water, then I immediately
started just lagging.
Me too, yeah.
Yeah, that's just the worst time possible.
It's all good.
I think the last game had easier lagging.
in this game.
Yep, yep.
Definitely last.
I would say, yeah, probably.
No, no, this lag was fucking crazy because it hit all three
of us.
Dude, the wagon that you were getting in this one was where
I have the first three, like, first three games where it's
like, it take you into the game, out of the game, into the
game, out of the game.
It's rough.
Yeah.
Now I understand why you were not having fun.
I was like, bro, I can't, like, because like, I would run
and then pause.
And I was just like, well, okay, well, just, I don't know if
I'll be alive.
Like...
You can't really tell like what's happening.
It's so bad.
Also like during that, we were fucked at in that rotation.
There were teams left, right, in front.
I literally couldn't go anywhere.
There's team behind us, team in front of us.
And then they get a safe rotation right after?
I know.
What the fuck is that?
That sucks.
They got both of them.
They got all six of us too.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen one of those KP?
How did he get a free rotation?
We got sandwiched by three different teams.
That's crazy.
They get the restart on the game where we had the best
positioning.
Dude, our rotation was so good, too.
We can't think about it, though.
We just can't think about it, man.
It is where it is.
I'm going to become heartbroken the more I think about it.
Okay, I already shed all my tears.
I could.
I'm drained.
I'm sorry, man, you're not going to get your prize money.
I apologize.
This one's on me, dude.
I owe you like 400 bucks.
Yeah, you should, you should, you should give some subs real
quick.
You'd like compensate.
I was like, I don't care.
Are you sure it's a free, it's a free win.
I did not say that.
I was like, do you want to do it this way?
You said, yes, it's a free win.
Free W is crazy.
No, no, no.
Fake news.
You can't say that with monsoons in there, man.
No, no, no.
Fake news.
I was like, yo, it's just vibes, bro.
Like, we have Whig as our third player, and he's like...
Yeah, I thought it would be vibe for us.
I thought he'd do all the hard work.
Oh, yeah.
I'm sorry.
I got it.
It should have been more specific there.
Yeah, you clear those comms.
I didn't know Apex servers are now like that bad now.
That sucks.
Yeah, dude.
It's like all creators that want to run like, um, like all
creators want to run like prime matches just can't.
This is what happens all the time.
That's crazy.
Like, dude, like the regular clothes are like regular
lobbies as fuck too, like the casual players?
If like creator lobbies are this fucked are the regular
lobbies that fuck too?
Yeah, it's not great, dude.
Jeez.
Man.
I remember back in the day there was no custom lobbies and
you just had to queue up public and see he gets more kills.
That was it.
I actually got into a scrim lobby because of that.
I was like queuing up uh trios with my like trios with my
friend and we got into a scrim lobby with like TSM and like
like like the when AC was still was cooked then.
Yeah no it was fun because like it was when AC was still in
pro play and then my friend and I were like wondering why no
one was dying like no team was dying and we like huddled up
in a house and saw like pro players like pro players in the
lobby like on the part right we're like oh my god did we
actually get into a stream lobby yeah you're cooked that's
crazy man when i wanted to restart we don't get it
this is the third or the fourth round this is the fourth
game so two more games left
apparently the last game that they restart someone was
actual god spot crazy sucks for them wait this team isn't
lagging the lag hit this team right now.
I don't think this is fair.
Can we, like, lag switch people?
Yeah, can we lag switch?
I demand this team to be lagging right now.
This team does not look like they're lagging.
I don't like it.
That makes me mad.
If I have, if my team has to go through lag, every team has
to go through lag.
Yep.
only fair yeah it's only fair we should be able if you kill
a team that's lagging you should get passed with the lag
like your team also should have the lag too infected yeah
yeah it's like infection yeah get infected with the fucking
lag there is fair if
anything every team should be lagging just to make it fair
and balanced.
Yeah, let's put the servers on like Dubai or something.
Yeah, we should, okay, oh my god, honestly, that's such a
great idea.
We should put the server in like the Middle East or
something.
So everyone should get, should be lagging.
Just to make it fair to the entire lobby.
The lag should accumulate and become harder as the game
progresses.
Now that's entertainment.
Take the lag and double it to the next person.
I like that idea.
Oh my god, there's still 10 teams.
This is not...
There's still 10 teams.
No, guys.
I mean, I messed up, but no, that sucks, though.
That really sucks that this tournament is just filled with
lag.
And it's been hitting my team the most, too.
Especially, wait, because he's been lagging the last four.
games as when he started tier 1 player so it's like very
hard as well I
didn't realize it was that bad now I
didn't realize yeah like cuz I haven't played these
tournaments in a long time so so I wasn't aware that lags
have now hit that hard like how like tournament lobbies are
like that now has this been like that wait for all the other
tournaments like like around the world or is it just n a
is it just an n a thing
is jp ones are fine like what the fuck why is n a server so
why are n a servers like that
that's unlucky i know this team was worse so for vibes but
it does suck it really does suck to die to to like like
that.
But it's like, we don't even have, like, I felt like we've
never had a real fight, dude.
I think that's what's frustrating.
Like, my team has not had a single real fight because of how
bad the lag is.
Because I think if all of us had, like, decent ping, or,
like, we'd actually have, you know, have, like, I want to
have a real fight.
It's not fun when I don't even get to shoot my gun.
There's no chance to actually play the game.
Yeah, I don't think I don't know I know I want to do
tournaments In the future if it's like this and then it's
but I don't know about do any tournaments if it's like this
And this might be my last one until they fixed the issue
because it's definitely not fun And you know I feel bad
because I invited wig and moxie to join me too And I don't
want them to have like, you know, this was my invite to them
to play with me And I don't want to like have them have a
bad time dude because of my invite Yeah, I know, like, oh, I
didn't restart when we are, we're, I wish they restarted
this one.
Like this, if we had a game like this one, then they
restarted.
Like, all the other, like, we had so many terrible lag
games, and then, like, um, this is the one that we were okay
in was the one that got restarted.
No one expected this, yeah.
But apparently, people are now, people are saying that it's
been like this for, uh, um it's been like this for uh for a
while now i haven't been keeping up to date so i didn't know
it was like this yeah no i'm glad moxie and wig are my team
because they're really fun people to play with i just wish i
could have given them a better experience you know because
it was my invite and also i could have gone to the dentist i
think this over the dentist because i was just So I
literally called today and they're like, yeah, the only
appointment we could get you.
Like I called the emergency dentist today.
But it's been like, I'm like not like, like the gum is
obviously swollen in the part where like.
And it's been very annoying today.
Today has been extra annoying.
So today's been like really, really bad.
I mean, not bad.
It's not painful.
That's the thing.
obviously the gum is swollen so it's so I'm like I like it
was so annoying to me so I was like thinking like oh I could
still eat solid food it's like my top left job I was like
they're like the only appointment we can get you today at
the emergency dentist is literally 12 p.m.
and then and I was like oh fuck okay
pick apex because I didn't want to back out like the last 30
minutes.
Like the tournament was going to start in 30 minutes.
I was like, I'm not back.
I don't want to back out like that last minute.
But I like, and I was like, you know, I'll tank it.
I'll tank it until Monday.
It's just swollen.
I can feel it swollen.
Because I'm trying to talk, but I feel that swollen gum.
Yeah.
Yeah, I didn't want to do them like that.
So I was just like, I'm already.
I mean, fuck.
All right.
Well, this sang guy's good.
That was good, man.
He's pro.
One of the best ballistic players in the world, if not the
best.
Damn.
Didn't even know that was his name.
I thought it was Fuse.
Sheesh.
I didn't even know that character existed.
Ballistic.
Sheesh.
He's good, man.
He's real good.
I feel like we should just change the server to, like, the
Middle East.
So everyone will start lagging.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we should just go to Dubai.
I get the Bahrain server going in this game.
We're not good.
Yeah.
Suggest that wait don't listen to you You should put that in
the suggestion Yeah, they'll listen to the uh last place
squad.
I think they would dude low key.
Yeah Yeah, I mean we have the highest chance to be fair We
are the only reason why we're plays that low is because the
servers have been fucking us Specifically our team Yeah,
I've yet to play a game without lag which is really just
devastating to be honest.
Yeah, so So, technically, we have an excuse.
It does make me sad.
Makes me pretty goddamn sad.
It's like teams that are below us, unless they're also
lagging.
If you're a team that is not lagging.
They're not fuckers, dude.
If you're not lagging, bro, fuck them.
Yeah.
You're not lagging.
Your opinion is invalid.
You're spitting off that one, dude.
Talk your shit.
Exactly.
If you're not below us, you're also opinion is invalid.
Yeah.
place are we probably very far last for sure we're 14th
right now oh wow honestly we have one good game how are we
14 like i think i think the other teams below us is also
lagging really badly they have to be bro we've done nothing
we've outgone like five times we scored two points in four
rounds here god damn genus yeah we got two kills in total
yeah they're lucky this is a marvel rivals
they're lucky dude oh people are saying the people that
aren't lagging are the ones that are like top five i wonder
like what they're doing where they're at why is it not
targeting them like i got nowhere i got the worst luck in
these fucking lobbies always it's probably my fault to be
honest that's crazy it's definitely your fault facts agree
dude they're literally like it's like taking the blame i
wasted no i feel everyone six games in a row it's like
they're like they're like it's like they're hunters or
something they're like going on a hunting trip and we're the
prey because we're lagging i mean i'm so desperate not to
lag i just changed my resolution for no reason come on yeah
maybe this will fix it oh they're just gonna fix it oh wait
what did they they banned Watson?
Good luck, dude.
All right.
I guess I played Lifeline.
Have fun.
You've learned.
Bro, I barely even played the character.
I got you guys the lobby code.
All right.
How many of those bad boys are in there?
A lot of them?
I don't know.
I just got it.
Oh, damn.
I just got the code.
I didn't even join in the code.
Sassy, dude.
Hates me.
Yeah, I'm right.
Yeah, it's crazy.
The one's like, no, my bad.
Yeah, I own it.
See, that's what you know, I'm not fake.
I'm not fake, though.
Facts.
I'm real to you.
Yeah, you mad real, though.
Yeah.
I'm a real homie.
I tell it how it is.
Look, I know you're real, but it's just, to me, it's so
funny that I, like, don't know what you look like.
And you're like, I'm real.
I'm like, dude, I know you are, but I don't.
I just...
That's what I look like.
Bro, it's not my fault.
You're so fucking busy in Japan there.
I know, dude.
Fuck, that was awful.
Dude, I don't get to hang out like ever.
I tried to meet up with you and you were like, oh, bro, I
can't.
Well, what goes on in Japan?
No, it was the part, like, there was a land in Japan.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was so fun, dude.
That was a good land.
Are you going to get it now?
Fair.
No.
Why is Apex so big in Japan?
It released like, so one of the main reasons was just
literally the PlayStation, dude.
Like right when it was released on PlayStation, it just took
the fuck off.
It was insane.
It was basically became the number one game for 2023, and I
think on PlayStation in Japan.
It was also the first shooter that got popular in Japan.
Like the first actual competitive, like, FPS game because
like in the past they never were into combat like shooters
like even like you know they have a Overwatch team for Japan
but like it wasn't as big as what Apex became I think the
closest would be I think the closest would be Valorant man
Valorant's fucking huge there too yeah it's getting bigger
and bigger but but like it was Apex first and then Valorant
yeah no Apex for sure yeah but now Valorant is more popular
than Apex I think in Japan I don't know, dude.
It's crazy.
The amount of people that are like, yeah, maybe like by a
player count, but the amount of like famous people in Japan,
like big names, like J-pop artists and shit that play Apex
is nuts.
It's like insane.
Nuddy.
I think it's just, it's because it's more fast pace.
He has Valorant just way too fucking slow.
And a lot of people like in Japan just play like Sony.
It's like their main thing there.
So like Roller on Apex is also just so good.
You can't really play Roller on Valorant.
Valorant, you can.
Exactly.
Yeah, it's so hard, dude.
You can't do it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, so that's why it's because Sony, every Japanese...
Oh, okay.
Every Japanese player.
A lot of, like, a professional play, too, for Japan,
majority of them are control players.
And then South Korea has, like, zero.
Literally no control players that play.
Yeah.
Because they're all, like, M&K, purists.
They hate us.
Like, they actually hate us.
I would die to, like...
I would die to show...
Don't worry, Wig.
I also hate.
God damn it, dude.
That's good.
I would die to like frozen South from South Korea and ranked
at like 4 a.m.
their time and they would just shoot my body for like five
hours.
Are you sure it's not me?
So long.
Are you sure?
Yeah, I'm sure.
Like I'm like shoot.
So you that was actually me.
I would.
You would shoot my body.
I would actually.
I should do that one day.
Remember we tortured nocturnal for like seven hours and
ranked us so far?
Oh, yeah.
It's like, I'm at.
What was that story I was trying to tell you?
The blue school is saying.
Blue school is story.
How the fuck did we even get there?
I don't know that at all.
Oh, what a time.
All right.
Resolutions changed.
That means no lag.
Let's get locked in.
I don't think that's how it works.
No, it is.
Oh, yeah.
So apparently.
We just got a rebirth here.
Come on.
Uh-oh.
We got a rebirth.
Come on.
Lock on in.
We decided who spawned.
where um i don't know doki how do you decide that what oh
you mean like in the actual dropship right now we don't
decide that oh okay okay yeah great content are you good
maybe a good change the devs can make wow moxie smart bro
yeah let's see what's just random yeah we should run back
our rank sessions again oh where's lifeline wait where's
lifeline wait where's life you want to do that
Yeah, bro, we should have a run back.
Bro, let's try to get Pred again together.
If you want to do it, just know I'm fucking down.
Guys, bang or a path?
Path, path, path, path, path.
Oh, are you getting Pred or what?
Oh, I'm getting Pred?
Yeah, bro, let's get Pred together, guys.
Holy fuck, imagine the ground we go on, that'd be electric.
Bro, imagine the stream snipers there to fuck us over.
No, I thought Moxie's stream snipers were friendly.
Oh, true.
Oh, my God, your stream snipers will feed us kills.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the land on us and give us, like, 20 Kp.
I'm going to go inside.
We get bad for that.
100%.
We definitely get bad.
Okay, but, like, we're not.
This only happened before ranked was even a thing.
That's why I got all these kills.
Oh, I see.
Okay, so we could just say, like, guys, don't do that.
But, like, we can't stop you.
You do want to land on us.
Also, I didn't see the gun ban.
What was the gun ban?
I have no idea either.
Also, I'm not lagging.
Did I define the fucking meta?
I am the one that got hit, but I'm not pausing.
The G7 scout is bad.
I'm not even.
Okay.
Well, no, it's been bad, but I have no idea what the new one
is.
Guys, what's the gun ban?
Does anyone know what the gun bans are?
Because I was not reading the chat.
Are you paying attention?
Chat, please.
Chat, chat.
Was that the battle fight?
Oh, apparently.
No, it's like, it was in chat.
Oh, it's Mozambique.
Who the fuck?
Oh, I guess double Mozambique.
Here's a sniper.
I think zones go in north pad like right next to us though,
by the way.
So.
Oh, that's not cool.
That's good.
No, it's good.
Let's get to an end game, man.
We don't have watch to do an end game.
We oh, fuck, dude.
Wait, we don't have us.
Wait, we have Moxie to scan zone.
Yeah, I'll scan zone.
Let me think where is this thing?
Oh, it's right there.
Oh, my God, lag.
Oh I'm a little bit I can't I can't scan I need I need blue
Oh yeah, you do.
Okay.
Um how and how?
There's no evo cash.
I don't think Wait, where's the closest evo cash?
I got one.
Oh, not even it's all at the top.
I get it.
I can maybe get it.
Okay Papa's gonna work for it.
Yeah, but he wouldn't even get blue off that though.
Doesn't even matter.
Are we fucked?
What about these dinosaurs up top?
i mean you can shoot if you want to shoot a dinosaur yep yep
yep did we go downstairs did you go to oh yeah you went
downstairs yeah yeah i went downstairs wait oh my god that's
the charge rifle wait i think it's known is here if they're
shooting us now all right it's gonna go it's gonna go north
path for sure i think we should start rotating honestly want
to just leave yeah sure all right come out this way we're
gonna go out this way so don't come to you guys no no come
to Yeah, come to us.
Come to us.
Yeah.
Good, good.
Good gun.
Oh shit.
That's your answer.
Yeah.
Make my way to me.
Okay.
I'm running over.
I'm slow.
The second this thing lets me go.
I'm heading over.
The slowest.
Oh, I'm sliding.
Yeah, we moving.
The slowest rotation.
Oh my God.
You could tell I'm lagging because you're fucking faster
than me.
I've had that momentum.
Holy shit, we're doing it.
Oh my god.
Oh, I messed up my man.
We're doing a damn thing.
Wait, another quick question.
Is the bow good?
This answer.
More of a bow guy.
Bow is good.
Bow is very good.
Bow S tier.
S tier.
Block in that Hanso real quick.
You.
And Haw guy.
I'm known as a bow guy.
Yeah, yeah.
The Hanso Haw guy.
Take the fucking bow.
Oh, well that's all the way back there.
Shit.
Oh, okay.
quick be hesitated fuck it's okay we'll find another boat we
can find another one self-watch any good anymore i heard it
is hell moxie's just like i'm out i'm over it i've got
another conversation all right wait follow me over here
follow me over you have a zip line or not yet yeah i got a
zip line all right cool cool nice let's keep on walking to
me we're gonna go to this rock don't zip line it though just
keep on
Keep it moving.
Keep it grooving.
I'm moving as much as I can.
They're doing great.
There's a dragon.
I'm going to put it out.
Open the ball for us to move fast.
Have a good one.
I'm going to shoot the dragon.
Get that damn dragon.
Fuck them.
All right, we're going to play on this rock.
So we got pegged.
Yeah, we got one in front of us, too.
People are shooting.
They're shooting the dragons or the prowess.
I don't.
bro this is insane holy lag bro this is crazy i have a
redeploy i do have a redeploy i think we stay here we're not
in that spot just keep looking around for us just all keep
holding different angles and stuff there's not a bad
position we can play here surely no one's good enough to
just to end us and like make an actual team calculate and
play i was gonna i should have grabbed oh i did not get ammo
i just realized i was not looting ammo all right dog what do
you need what do you heavy and light oh you have some light
here here somebody's what it's five so you should keep it i
just have light for about a night i want to i do your
children okay okay yeah because i have one stack of each i
got 300.
well oh my god he's rich he's rich as well okay i'll take it
i'm rich in thermites guys i'm rich in thermites so you say
i'm rich in pennies bro like i'm rich in and nades that's
all you need to know some shit coin I'm ripping I'm rich in
crypto zoo dude I'm rich guys you guys look at that I'm
invested guys I invested in NFTs holy fuck I have so much
ammo to shoot a sniper this whole time I'm gonna miss every
shot but I'm just gonna do it yeah but I need that I need
that blue yep same right I'm gonna look for it behind us in
case we get flanked from behind yeah good comms good comms
out of that guy could kick rocks he's shooting so far if he
had shots me i'm dead if that hits i'm dead got a ballistic
over there because they just shot a ballistic thing
bitch yeah let them know yeah don't you got any uh long
rangers yeah yeah i'll give you my long range gun here oh no
long range scope oh yeah i do here 3x oh my god oh my god
that's there you rich now you want a 1x okay i dropped it
yeah such a good teammate dude wow that's actually close
never do that for me would never do that for me shot my dog
never that's why you know that i'd be better friends with
than you with you than him i'll be w yeah oh my god i
actually because i've done zero damage in 50 bullets so yeah
so you know that wig like you're you're you're my homie
because i would never give you damn oxy she said your dog
that's crazy no no i'm just saying that I'm uh wig is I know
wig for longer so I know I don't he doesn't do shit yeah so
you can just be mean to me all the time facts it's tough
tough love bro that's why my dad hates me type shit it's
okay I'm here to remind you of your dad shot my pops for
real oh my god you get shit on oh what is this zone what the
fuck is this whoa um hey I thought you said we were in zone
bro they don't to have fun today all right we're gonna have
to make some major adjustments this is insanity okay so what
we're gonna do here let's go up here we're going to this
gazebo up front south side gazebo right in front of us okay
we're here walk up on this bad boy this is a crazy zone holy
i'm not lagging anymore i'm not either don't shoot the
prowess either though oh okay okay don't i'm not gonna get
as you said that dude you cast a curse on me
Do not push me bro chill dude.
Oh shit.
Oh, I got heavy man.
Oh, I'm sure that all 33 are bitter nice I'm gonna grab that
now All right, keep a lookout for where people are.
I'm not too sure There's gonna be people around us no doubt
about it and the bow shit.
Oh, you can grab the bow now 40
Oh my god.
Oh no, you're fighting about that.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no, no I cracked my cracked one.
Here I put him all down.
Push me, push this.
Yeah, skidolky.
You got me.
Oh my god, you hit me!
One shot.
One shot right side.
Nice.
I left.
I got you.
One shot.
You can tap me again.
You can tap me.
I got it.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh my.
Come on, Toki.
Good job.
Oh, let's go.
Oh, my shit on you.
Okay.
I just need you to know you almost killed me when you're
all.
No, no, no.
Calculated.
You almost killed me when you're all broken.
Gonna be honest, guys.
I was about to run away immediately when you died.
I was about to run away immediately.
But I believe in you guys, bro.
I believe in you guys.
Oh, my God.
We actually had a fight.
I'm so happy.
Wait, guys, I was watching.
Oh, my God.
Moxie died.
Moxie knocked was a bait.
That was a bait.
You should have seen how I played that with 10.
I did no damage.
Good job.
Like, this guy was so scared to push me when I had 1-8 feet.
It was insane.
You were a good bait.
Confidence.
We're going to move up near me.
Just keep doing that, guys.
Keep baiting me.
Yep.
Got you, baby.
How do we win that on white armor as well?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
That was crazy.
Wait, ring consoles or surveys?
Oh, right now it doesn't really matter.
I would do rings, but I don't even know if we're going to
hit one for you anyway.
Just keep it up.
Just keep this.
Don't take anything yet.
Oh, no, we're going to take it.
We're going to play it.
That's okay.
That's actually the smart move.
We're good.
We're also, we're going to stay underneath here for a little
while.
I got all three kills.
So we got three points.
Oh my God.
Let's fucking go.
That's good.
That's huge, bro.
That's huge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to play you for a little bit.
Only 13 squads up.
This is really good.
Like really good at two or nine.
I love that the one game we're lagging.
We're not lagging.
There's no one alive, but it's kill.
It's all good.
Don't worry.
That's good.
We got placement points too.
True.
100%.
All right.
You guys stay here.
I'm going to do some recon.
Just don't die on me.
And I will die on you, maybe.
Okay.
All right, so there's a team over here.
All right, we're gonna do, we're gonna fight those guys
later.
We're gonna fight them later once the zone closes.
That's the first team we're gonna fight in gazebo.
Is anyone scouting behind us?
I think we're good for right now, because I think everyone
that was behind us moved in, but we'll see.
Just keep watching behind on the northeast side.
Should be cool.
Great fight though, dude.
Good job.
How much have you guys got?
How much you got?
I have...
700, 200.
120 and 216.
Yeah, one, one, three, one three.
Oh, ammo?
Oh.
at least i said damage i said damage 150 yeah okay okay yeah
i got 150 with three kp yeah yeah i'm gonna kill that matter
you know yeah that's why i'm not agree yeah i got a lot too
one three huge huge nice 13 or 130.
no no uh 13.
oh yeah no no no remember you were the bait yeah don't
forget we don't forget you were the calm cool calculated
when they're all right guys this is the moment of truth
right now okay we need fight these guys i have a redeploy i
have a redeploy i don't think we do it either we fight these
guys okay we have to okay double checking behind us just i
pk all good that's fine no worries we need to get we need to
fight these dudes this is the team we need to kill do i
shoot them oh they're inside here they're close yeah people
shoot them yeah 100 100 we shoot them we see them shoot them
we need to keep moving up though i'm just gonna break
there's the people closer there's people like close yeah oh
wait okay well they know where behind them now because i
shot the wall that's fine we need it's okay it's just chill
we need to kill them so it doesn't matter i'm gonna look
behind just in case because they i'm worried that this a
team would come from here it's fair it's fair what the fuck
did i got you're good you're good yeah you're good you're
good now it's mad maggie no worries though good comes i'm
just looking back here just in case yeah you're good you're
good i think we i think we got to push up a little bit ducky
though i want to push up we got to kill these guys for sure
Share it.
Okay.
Those guys have to die or we just lose.
Do we know whether I mean actually wait a minute?
Wait, yeah.
you have a zip, you have a zip line?
You have a zip line?
Yep.
Zip, zip, zip.
All right, come here.
Can we, come here, come here, come here, go here, come here,
go here.
Okay.
Come back, come back.
We're gonna make this play fast.
Let's do it.
We're doing a risky play.
I believe.
All right, you see like this lobstere tail?
Yep.
Like this thing.
Zip to that.
Oh, yes.
I'm ping.
okay under under right yep yeah yeah anywhere you can go yep
all right take this bitch get active baby we're good now
we're so good we're so good all right we're gonna keep it
moving keep going there for you keep going this way to me
okay yep oh we're chilling guys and we're gonna play here
this is where we're playing right yeah yeah fifth game this
is a great start oh there's a there's supposed to get giz.
True, true, true.
There's a bat here.
Okay, yeah.
I have a alt Excel.
I'm 20 on my alt.
I'm going to look behind us.
50 now.
I scanned the care package.
Nice.
Good scan.
It's a car.
I'm bad.
All right.
All good.
I'm good.
I'm just looking here.
Just in case.
What are the people above us?
Do we?
That's fine.
If there's someone above us, just try to ignore it.
Just try not to just try to analyze it as much as possible.
Yeah, here.
Northwest side, 285.
It's a charge rifle.
So watch out.
We're still in zone.
We're on that.
We're fine.
Yeah.
I'm looking here.
There's a team in this cup.
There's a team in this hole.
Yep.
Keep standing on that, Doki, if you can.
Just keep putting pressure on him.
Try it.
Don't pick me, pussy.
Yeah.
Let him know.
Let him know, dog.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let him know.
Hit him again.
65.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
It's here.
You're good.
I'm dead.
Oh, they can't.
They walked all the way behind.
They're good.
Keep moving up.
Keep going.
No, they're going to kill me now.
They're not pushing it.
Oh, I might be dead.
No, they're gonna keep moving.
Keep them back.
They're taking a zip right now.
Just play for your life.
Yeah, run, run, run, run, run.
I'm dead.
Go forward.
Go forward if you can.
My zip fucking didn't do shit.
I'm dead.
i just bad ah the moment i turn over they give you heels
dude they walked up on me i need a run they're gonna find me
yeah just rat just rat i'm trying it's bad they're looking
at me i'm liking to oh no not the lag just keep right here
no i don't think he can race i don't think he can rent just
i'll make you breast even cut me moxy oh no nevermind oh no
it's really not where for me to go to be honest so just just
get that heel up though oh no just play play I'm trying.
It's like nowhere for me to play this.
I think they rotated when I gave Moxie the heel drone.
Tick-tack what happened.
That was the most unfortunate time possible.
Yeah, because I didn't see it.
I was like, look, I've been looking at that door for the
rotation.
Now, it could have been worse timing for you.
It sucked.
Yeah.
I hate timing so much.
Yeah, I was called.
Did he timing, honestly?
That's okay.
You can chill.
You're a little rat boy.
Yep, right here.
Just right here.
Don't need to shoot.
Just be a little rat.
Little rat, baby.
Just a little baby.
I believe in you so much I'm going to go pee.
It's okay.
Coms, I think.
Get by on this one.
Type shit.
I'm so fucking dead.
Next zone.
You're the only solo.
much it comes holy shit did no one look at me please sweet
sweet bill
right by the ring got 45.
come on bro give me a top five kids another fucking two
teams die for the love of god man
rings near with 30 to go please bro please god
you're still alive
Come on.
Just give me a top five.
Top five.
Holy shit.
My cam is frozen, chat.
My cam is frozen.
I'm locked in right now.
It's just technical difficulty.
I have to turn a wheel for you every day.
There's been a lot of technical difficulties when I've
noticed.
Oh my god.
If you killed him, you could have been top five.
How is he alive though?
He should die.
He's not dying.
How did he freeze?
It's so free!
I don't understand how he's alive.
Wait, just keep waiting.
Maybe this is it.
He had a teammate.
There's no way.
There's no way you have to crawl up.
Top four.
Oh, they see you.
They see you.
They all see you.
Top four!
A thousand damage, though!
A thousand damage!
Three kills!
gone man top four top four top three no no top no no we we
were for it for four i don't know popped on my screen top
three like spectating i guess oh it's the last is the oh
what oh i thought that was the rat this is how we play guys
yeah top four plus three more kills let's go what is that
that's um that's uh do my math here nine or eight points
can't remember i feel like i feel like if all of us were
alive i think we would have a low replacement i think so too
yeah because like you as a rat you get to you get to be like
you know by yourself so no one could see you you know yeah
you don't have two ducks following you around give up your
location so you being the rat actually are these why do you
so scared of two people there's three of you guys there's
actually have a point maybe next round that we i i i i could
just sit there and no no because placement points don't
matter next round you have to get all the kills oh i
actually have to do stuff now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
have to get kills or why it's crazy we don't lag and look
what happens insane unbelievable wait they lose this wait
they lost wait they lost this we want to be two i don't mind
might be one though but it's a 1v1 it's a new castle oh my
god that res clutched it he almost died because of the res
dude that was the ballsiest ever i
can't believe they lost that wow
all right now it's just all up to moxie to earn kp yeah i
got it No, I'm like, oh my God.
There's no placement points either.
So everyone's just going to run at each other.
Or maybe wait till end game until they start running.
I don't know.
We're so good, dude.
I mean, we just got a good amount of points, dude.
Yeah, yeah.
We got some good-ass points there.
We'll get it.
Let me listen, bro.
That's what, eight, nine?
Come on.
Yeah, that's a lot of points there.
I just exiled my apex by accident.
Son of a biscuit.
me man where am i doing my you're your boy cage is 76 come
on man come on baby let's go dude now we can never be last i
mean no like you actually might not know it's all good no
don't say that don't say that now there's no way we can be
last now yeah yeah there's no way
wait how many points is fourth place uh five um i think
format fourth place is five points five points okay so we
got eight points there yeah hey maybe a little top maybe a
little top 12 in the leaderboard then yeah yeah yeah we
could get that yeah we have to be close to it now no yeah
yeah we've moved up here we've moved up
I should be fine now
we're moving up in the world That's how we play.
Ain't going to move down in the world.
Yeah, yeah.
We could always go up.
Not with you, my boy.
Come on.
Only way this is up.
If you guys actually want to play ranked at one point, let
me know.
I'm down.
I'm super down.
Potentially.
Sheesh.
I got to look at this game again.
I have Loki had an itch for Apex.
He's got to look at the tier list.
You gotta make him a tier list, Whig.
I have to know, huh?
Why don't you make tier lists?
Do people not like that on the tube?
Not real.
I mean, I never tried it.
Maybe you maybe just conjure something up.
I'll try it.
Yeah, you gotta make a tier list for the YouTubes.
Yeah, I'm gonna try it, actually.
And then have everyone judge it.
Be like, are you fucking stupid?
Why is this gun on S-Rank?
Are you stupid?
Like...
Just get shit on the whole time in the comments.
Yeah, that'd be like, It's just my most dislikes video.
I just blame Moxie.
Yeah, yeah.
It would be like Moxie, how could you?
You listen to an unranked player.
You just tell me the tier list and I'll just make it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, you write the tier list.
This is like pure rage bait.
I don't know.
Legend 301 felt pretty nice when I was using it.
Thanks.
That's true.
What are you thinking?
Hmm.
Oh, they banged the damage.
Bangalore is bad now.
I mean, we're not playing Bangalore.
So we shouldn't because it really matter to us.
No, we can stay on the comp.
If you guys want, if you're comfortable, I'm cool with it.
I mean, that comp was fine.
I think so too.
Yeah.
Should I try to grapple out and it went on cooldown.
I didn't even touch anything.
I'm sick.
Yeah.
All right.
Are you confident on getting kills on with Pathfinder?
Sheesh so only his kills can't matter right now placements
don't matter only kill points from moxie.
Oh shit.
That's insane Okay, okay, let me think let me think then
What what character do I need to go in and gun people down
here?
Hmm, I mean bang wars not bam guys, I'm gonna be honest.
I don't know if the character really get matters in this
scenario here Sheesh This is a big task
I mean, Revenant's not a bad call.
Yeah, you want to play Revenant?
That's the guy who goes on dying?
That's the guy.
Oh, you get armor.
Revenant's pretty fun.
Good.
When you all.
Yeah, you got like jumps, like crazy leaps, like path
underground, but even better.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I've played that character then.
Ballistic, too.
He's so good.
I played that character then.
Maybe I will go to Revenant.
Yeah, you also got a little bit of extra shield on the ulti,
so be crazy.
Oh, I forgot to tell you, I do have a loba on me.
A loba on you?
Yeah, but loba is not very aggressive, though.
Hey, throw my teleporter in, boom, sock dead, you know?
It's a tractor with her gigantic fucking butt.
What do I do?
Start waltzing around on that, Matt, bro.
Maybe you should be on loba, then.
it'll just be bait for you yeah i'll just email dude i'll
get i'll get that goner skin they'll be good to go and get
them distracted oh so we're in the lobby by the way so
revenant doesn't so revenant doesn't make me invulnerable
like it doesn't like let me no no it just gives you armor
yeah what character was that then no it was him but then he
like got like reworked oh we got reworked yeah yeah oh so
you're thinking the old one yeah you know he's different now
different now why does it only vtuber kills this game that
is not true i do first off i don't even get to have kill
points here okay
so moxie what what is your what's your plan revenant
revenant now sheesh pro i could have played revenant a while
ago i think forgot that character existed all right so
there's no placements and it's kills only that's so crazy
for you two or only him it's only him holy shit okay i'll
fuck with that so if i don't if i kill the whole lobby yeah
if you kill the whole lobby we'll actually get first place
i'll pay you a thousand dollars yeah i would also pay pal
you like i'll double it come on guys i'll double it three
grain on the line right now three grand mockery if you can
kill everyone and guess for place.
If you even get his first place, you get three grad.
Okay.
All right.
Sit back then.
No pressure.
No pressure at all.
You want me to shoot or you want me to just to dance a
little bit?
What do I do?
Just sit back and dance and watch the show.
Okay.
I don't think we're gonna, I don't think we're gonna get his
first place.
Should I play a ranch character?
Oh, what have you?
Should I play crypto to get like banners and stuff?
Oh, wait, that's smart.
I like that.
Yeah, I'm I like that.
I'm gonna go crypto.
I'm horrible at him, but it's easy.
I get the bang.
I'm gonna go back.
That's fine.
I'm gonna do that.
So no G7, have a triple take.
Repeat.
Repeater is bad.
Low key, not that good of guns anyway, so it's fine.
I mean, I got those kills with a repeater, but don't care.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One of my kills was with a repeater.
Or two of my kills were with a repeater.
Those are the R9 gamer there.
ready get me in this goddamn lobby let's dominate yeah i
mean let's let's watch you dominate my bed and then let's
all play rivals after you have oh your grandma sunday's my
off day man i hopped on for y'all i'm usually doing nothing
but just fucking we just we're gonna consist of rivals after
party guys all i do on sundays is take an edible and just I
literally drew out of my mouth That's my surba No, but I
fucking should have dude How much that lag would have
tripped me out though Being high and lagging?
Holy fuck Yeah, you'd be having a bad trip though Oh my god,
a crazy one Maybe it would have been so good That I would
have like maybe felt normal Cause I'm high The lag would
have affected me
Nah, I feel like you're a guy that goes outside No I mean
you go outside and have a bad trip like it's not exclusive
you don't go outside moxie i feel like you go outside you up
all the time come on it's loud that's my home right there
outdoor activity uh outdoor activity um by bikes okay
motorcycles bicycles yeah just naming something random two
wheels yeah no i think he's lying to me for sure yep walking
Yeah, yep, walking is an activity outside.
Where do you walk?
The beach?
Uh, the...
Uh-huh.
Just, I like getting my steps up.
It makes me feel productive, you know?
Yeah, how many steps?
It doesn't matter really where.
How many steps do you get a day?
I used to get 10K, but now I'm getting one.
Maybe 1K.
Oh my...
Wait, what happened?
I don't know.
What the fuck is that fall off, dude?
Holy shit.
I don't know.
I used to be 10k in minimum.
That was the walk king.
That's what people used to call me.
The walk king.
Oh, yeah.
The king of walking, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Where's the, okay, Revenant.
Get him.
That's Ash.
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit.
Bro, what the hell?
Oh, just because she's also a robot, she looked the same to
you.
A little bit of racism there.
Oh, yeah.
It's a little bit.
racism i don't know if i yeah i bet you say i i bet you say
the c word with a hard r don't you oh my god you sick yeah
you're so sick bro all right listen moxie it's all of you
baby yeah it's all you i'm grabbing a gun i'm running people
down not not not not not flatline perfect perfect gun i'll
get your banner we'll get active well you'll get active not
me and we're good to go What'd you what do you do?
Oh, you're resting him.
Okay.
Got it.
I understood the move.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah He goes in and then I res him No havoc allowed Oh
wait this lobby this lobby is pretty good The last game I'm
not lagging.
Are you lagging?
We should just play more dude.
What the fuck?
No, not at all.
We should just play more.
Wait, what the fuck?
Dude, I hate apex.
Never mind I'm lagging.
Oh, okay.
I'm still fine I'm definitely better this game for sure yeah
this game is definitely a lot better about the you know it's
kind of crazy we had fun last game a little bit yeah when we
not when we were like surviving and not lagging our ass out
there it's a good time who would have thought oh the but oh
yeah what you getting over there bro you're getting real
real into what should you sign sexual over there i didn't
know you could charge with a with a grenade yep yep a little
exploding arrow oh yeah you should get a bow check right
your bread and butter the bow yeah i got it wait uh wake is
the hemlock good or now yeah i'm gonna stop that i'll grab
that then i'll grab the hemlock yeah no squads near us by
the way yeah what's the point okay dope no point of even
asking this guy what gun is good all right whoa whoa yeah
you can't you can't do that okay what's about right now
flatline b tier b tier Oh, shit.
No, oh, see, dearest.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'll come home.
We're good.
I'm ready to go.
Who are we fighting?
Oh, check my best here.
They're they're up top at zoo station.
We can go fight them if we want to.
Do we want to go hot ground?
No, this is so asked.
The fact that we did it doesn't matter if a placement in the
zones any on us.
This kid.
The zones ending.
Oh, my God.
That's just I guess for sure.
No, this is 100% rigged.
They did not want us to have a good.
time yeah guys let's run people down no yeah yeah yeah
whenever you're ready moxy you're the leader you're here
yeah okay okay okay um yep i got a flat line in the boat
check all right i'm right behind you all right where do we
go are we going up we're gonna zeus let's go let's go let's
go oh shit up there yeah we're fucking hitchhiking dude
let's go should i forget we can still shoot so if we get
damage it's all good oh my god i just found like fucking
three bats in a row i got three meds four bats come on guys
we got gas gas gas one squad near us one squad near us i
don't know where they're at i'm trying to look out for them
My recon drone my drone wait flying on guys flying on us by
by in Southwest southwest Oh, I'm good.
I'm becoming I'm bored.
I need one where oh, yeah another team two on us Unlocks
you.
Oh my god.
Oh, my man.
Not going on.
I knocked one.
I knocked when you're good.
I'm having anger what this It gives you armor gives you
armour Oh my god.
I'm trying to look for you.
Oh my god.
I don't play this fucking stupid standard He had shot me.
He had shot me I'm gonna times, I'm gonna be him.
MPM MPM.
Yeah, yeah.
He gave me a edge shot i was trying to make it and then i
got hit
it's fine it's fine okay i get you i get you i get i
literally got 150 i was trying to peek and throw a hand and
then i got needed And my guy headshot You're good.
It's okay.
Just craft this.
Yeah, watch this.
Wait, you need to die Just die.
Moxie, just die Okay, you want me to run to him?
No, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, just let him shoot you What the fuck?
Why did they not kill Moxie, bro?
Bro, what the fuck?
Just back grab B.
Oh, no.
Oh wait, but grab him too far.
Yeah, I don't think too far I just you just craft this.
Moxie, I'm a yeah, I can't fuck it.
Whatever it's craft this, bro Another team, bro.
Another squads monsoon.
Are you serious?
It's fucking monsoon, bro.
It's a piece of shit, dude.
Bro, why is he taking shots, bro?
You don't need the kills!
Monsoon, fuck off, dude.
You don't even...
I feel like you could just go invisible.
Yeah, I'm better right now.
We don't fuck anymore.
You just gotta go invisible at this point.
I'm gonna.
Just like hide and seek.
This fucking piece of shit, dude.
No squads around us.
No squads.
They leave us?
You think he's trying to find you you slide down.
He slide down.
Yeah Grab the fucking banner you piece of shit But you can
raise him here.
I know I know I'm gonna get you guys up because I'm about to
die I'm gonna get you two No, I'm gonna be closer.
No, no, Jack Jack oh my god, how far am I to this can I get
you?
No, I'm too far.
No, you have to stay in the portal.
He's gonna I know I know you.
What's that?
No, no, no, you need to shoot.
Why did you save this?
I'm getting red.
I'm gonna get red.
I'm regardless that over on top.
Look at that lady.
No, no, no, no, these guys.
No, no, these guys.
No, these guys, no.
Doesn't matter.
Watch this.
You're getting a shot at, bro.
You're gonna, there's no way.
There is no way.
No, no, no.
There is no.
You got to stay in that.
Don't matter.
I'm getting you up.
I was not.
It doesn't matter.
These guys saw my drone come down.
It didn't matter.
I was dead as far.
No, we're gonna go.
We're gonna go.
We have two teams over here.
There's two teams here.
So, one here on top here as well.
Bro, why the f-I'm so mad that we got zoned.
I'm so fucking mad.
I should be going to kill Kiki over here.
There's all fighting right now.
All fighting over here.
Are they?
Okay.
Yeah they are!
There's a smoke box ahead.
It has to be.
You have to fight.
Hey!
Okay!
It's their own thing.
Are they all dead?
Oh my god.
Should I go on the roof?
Yes.
Love it.
Come on.
we got this man you're good you're good you're good you're
good oh zip zip zipped on me oh yeah inside they're purple
armor they're purple armor i don't think it's possible oh my
god there's a purple armor bro you need to run i'm going to
be leaving i'm going to be running i can't right boxy you
have to run you have to run you have to run okay i think
you're out i think you're out you know maxi get out get out
get out he's moving he's moving oh he's moving moxie just
leave i'm out just leave i have it i have two teams on me no
don't i know you're actually i think you're both good i
think you're both good which is insane i mean that but mean
that no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no we gotta go craft him though numbers baby no there's
nowhere to craft me nowhere to craft me at all oh my god
we're fucked we lost our one okay no you're fine you're fine
you're fine you're fine listen you just need to fight i
think you rat in this building i think you rat this building
i'm not kidding i think you sit in the corner and when a
chain walks in you explode them i don't think you make a
sound i don't think so either we gotta just yeah i think
when they walk in you fuck their day up dude if anyone does
walk in no you have to go on different corner you have to go
you got you go there you go there you go in a different
corner you go in my in the corner get in your chair bro get
in the chair in the chair this chair is a good monthly oh
yeah baby why the did we get zoned i don't know i'm so mad
we get zoned this one time dude so mad insane and it doesn't
even matter places don't even matter makes no sense okay you
can bow check moxie yep is this one shot yep it's not one
it's not it's not there's no it's it's a lot of damage
though i'm all i got 40 bullets what do you mean that's on
one shot
You got this, man.
You got this.
Good shot.
Yeah, get that blue armor, bro.
Get that blue armor.
You guys are killing it, man.
Listen, there might be a crafter that comes down to you.
That's true.
Yeah, it's going to be you.
If it does come down, it's going to be you.
Okay.
Because you got to move it.
You got to move it.
Yeah, I got to be the one that sacrificed myself for him.
Moxie, you got to get that those kills.
Moxie, you got to get those kills.
Keep shooting those arrows.
Keep shooting the arrows, man.
Nice.
Good shot.
Sniping them.
Yeah, no, you're right there.
You're so close.
Oh, my God.
That was a great attempt, bro.
one more great shot dude i mean one of these have to hit i
think so i think you're getting there yeah oh my god they
know i have they know i have white armor they know i have
white armor now they're pushing they're pushing yeah they
know just leave just leave just leave just leave just leave
just right just run just run like there's no point there's
no point nice moxie just make it Just make it.
They're not cheap, they're not cheap.
Oh.
Motherfucker!
Let me live.
Oh, yeah.
I don't even think I can.
Oh, wait.
No, you got it.
You got it.
You got a final one.
I'm going to find a crafty.
Let's go.
Cascade.
That's one.
No.
This is disfusion.
No, it's not.
You're never not here.
Nope.
They actually changed.
They actually taste These fucking Pussies, dude Bro, why did
we get fucking Zoned?
Bro, that is so cringe, man.
Oh my god, this is sad.
One time we don't want it, we get it, bro.
This entire tournament was against us.
Actually Against us.
There is no fucking way.
These guys, like, rushed us just because, like, Oh my god.
At least we gotta play A little bit in the last two games,
though.
yeah yeah not this one though like maybe the last yeah we
got it we got a little bit of play that last game yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh they died for it they died for it yeah
that's right they died for chasing after us yeah yeah yeah
that's right yeah that's right the fuck's up baby oh my god
we had no lag and we got zone that's actually up that is so
one game mode that zone does not matter man yeah that's what
you're right left their spot and they died for it these
sickos is this monsoon i think so i think it is can't tell i
can't tell they're not looking at their teammates oh they're
getting ran out bro that sucks i would have loved to like
actually have a fight there but we had like 20 teams run at
us because it was full on zone two i'm kidding there oh my
god we got walls on bro we ran we had to run across every
map i know we had to run across every map oh i'm just glad
i'm not a pussy like these guys so yeah exactly yeah yeah
we're not pussies at least oh he said bro why couldn't we
get this on the other keys i don't understand oh ggs guys
ggs man fucking geez i think i'll drive home in la traffic
now bro oh yeah you got the traffic to go through it'd be
like three and a half hours for four miles my life's a movie
for real so dope lagging irl i'm sick dude oh yeah yeah like
like here like there oh fuck it man why not all right i love
you guys bro ggs thank you all for playing it it was fun 100
great time yeah yeah even with our terrible luck it had a
good time everybody around until that point man it was a
vibe it was a vibe is gonna be a vibe you know that's all we
wanted so i wanted that's it so i wanted to catch a field
you know yeah i said we got it multiple sadly i think we got
it like five out of six rounds we got yeah yeah i felt
something some anger for sure sometimes i ended up yeah i'm
just gonna talk to my therapist all right peace out guys all
right bye guys love you all and peace later all right ggs i
mean i had a great time with boxing away we know what we're
getting into when we signed up we were like, yeah, that's
gonna be uh, yeah, we were I did, okay, look, with the team
name and everything, we knew what we were getting into.
Uh,
but like, uh, it was fun, though.
That was just so unlucky.
It was just, um, it was just really unlucky.
I mean, it really doesn't matter who wins that rep map.
It's all about, it was all about uh, kills.
So it's like whichever team had the most kills.
Um, Yeah, it was just, it was just like, it was just unlucky
with the, with the lag and everything.
And then the moment we stopped lagging, Zone was on us.
It's just a very unlucky, unlucky RNG there.
Yeah, it was like, what can you do?
Yeah, definitely what can you, I think, I don't know, I
don't even think if they like delayed the tournament.
If they delayed the tournament, it's not really going to
change anything.
universal problem.
Yeah.
We got the vibes, but at what cost?
Um, um, but I had a fun time.
I really enjoyed playing with both Moxie and Wig.
I knew like having them on my team.
Um, I knew having both of them on my team, it was, uh, it
was gonna be really fun because I knew like, you know, Wig's
a really fun guy to play with and Moxie was a really fun guy
to play with too.
So I knew like having all three of them together like it
would be like a good back and forth with everyone um so you
know not last our goal was to not get last and we did it
yeah rivals after party i don't really want solo cute rivals
i mean i could ask yo moxy you wanna rivals after party my
stream rivals
don't want to solo queue right now uh i ping moxie if he
wants to rival his after party um but yeah it was fun i mean
i had a like the one time the one time that we had a real
fight wow we won
isn't that crazy like we actually had a real fight and then
we won the game that's insane who would have sunk it yeah
and then like all the other time yeah funny how that works
and they the crazy part was that they we were one man down
like Moxie was fully down, and we still won the fight.
It was literally a 2v3.
And he also did 13 damage in that entire fight, too.
That's crazy.
He did 13 damage in that entire fight.
But he was good bait.
He baited everyone.
Oh, Moxie can't do it.
He said he has to do a top 500 solo Q on tank.
um so he can't he can't do it right now um so i'll just call
it here then i'll just call it here i was just like oh i
don't really want to solo here right now you're right 13
damage is is 13 damage i told you did he did um he did we
was good bait he got them all rushing us and we still won
the the fucking 2v3 um yeah now yeah we need we need a
weapon tier list for him yeah
Like, I'm like sitting and like, what can I, like, you know,
I can't really go to a dentist today because it's fully
booked.
It's tomorrow, so I hope they can fix the problem tomorrow.
But I had a fun time vibing with Wig and Moxie.
I mean, I haven't played in a long ass time, so I knew I
knew what I was getting into.
It's just unfortunate.
I wish I wish the servers weren't lagging so we could have.
had like real fights I think I think if it wasn't lagging
and we actually had like a real fight it definitely I mean
obviously for anyone it would always be more fun you know I
feel like I think we all know if we had a real fight it
would obviously be a lot more fun to play so it's just that
um I think like if I ever get future apex invite tournament
invites um If I get another Apex tournament invites, I will,
I will look into whether or not the servers are fixed
because I really don't want to do that again.
I really, I know like, even if I get like a fun team to play
with, I don't think it's not fun playing like, like I, like
I was so laggy.
I tried not to get super tilted when, when I was literally
that one game where we had to, where I was like literally
like pausing every time.
um when i was literally pausing every time it was just like
it was just way too much i was trying not to get fucking
tilted there but i was so i like i was really tilted at that
because like because it was just it was just way too much
like i couldn't even like do any movement stuff yeah um so
if i do get another future apex tournament invite i'm
actually just gonna i'm just gonna check if it's like if
like um yeah we were like literally floating
and it sucked i think the worst part was just the fact that
of all the games they choose to restart it was that game too
that like made me really tilted because it's like you didn't
restart like i know that's like really hard to pick but it's
like picking and choosing when to restart you either restart
all the games or like you go on with it because you know
like there's nothing else you can do yeah i was just like
i'd have to restart after either keep it consistent on
restarting games or just don't restart and it was such a
late restart too yeah yeah it was way too late too yeah we
had a really good spot so that like tilted me that's why i'm
like saying i don't want to be like that tilted again so
even though i came in there for fun um um either uh they
they uh came either like i just wanted to like i just want
to know if the lobbies are still like that the lobbies are
still gonna be like that i won't join another tournament
like that just because it was like also like i saw the
channel where people were complaining and it was just like
there was just like everyone's just like being like lag lag
lag like the literally top five like the first place team
was complaining about the lag like because they're like we
died to lag and i was like duh and you know for a first
place team that really fucking sucks too because you know
they could easily lose first place because of the lag too so
i saw like it was like you know that's not fun in general um
but yeah anyway um love playing with moxie and wigg um i
really enjoyed like you know moxie and wigg met met each
other for the first time today and it didn't really seem
like that um and had a good time i really uh they're really
cool people to play with um i hope you guys had fun just
hanging out today as well as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and blood flowing and you need to stay
up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'm just gonna
chill maybe i will stream rivals later i don't know depends
on how i feel later um i'll take a little break because like
i said i haven't had anything to eat too i haven't had lunch
at all i went straight in here um because i woke up like
third like an hour before i woke up an hour before the
tournament so i'm gonna go grab some food now um but thanks
for watching everyone thank you I might do a Monday stream.
Oh, wait, no.
No, I won't do a Monday stream.
Monday's my dentist.
So most likely Monday and Tuesday, I won't be streaming
because I'll be recovering from the dentist stuff.
So, yeah.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.